and we
are
live what's up everybody
ibontus here with the last word tonight
on this thursday night we are without
lord cognito that man is in recovery
mode because he is working he's burning
the candle i think on every end possible
right now so we are going to hold down
the last word campfire without him but
we have
of course my co-host who is the most
dapper dressed as usual what's up ty guy
how you doing
how you doing that's a pretty good cog
impression for your intro if i could
give you one piece of no just you know
okay
as a as a thespian an aspiring you know
uh
um
one of those nights everybody it's trash
you missed that you missed the pre-intro
giggle oh uh where he where he goes
we are live you know that you got to do
the giggle before you say that we are
live i feel like it's a very important
part of this intro
other than that though
other than that spot-on just i have to
say chef's kiss what do you mean
beautiful beautiful i'm uh i'm reviewing
a video game right now i cannot talk
about it um
officially but in may
i'm trying to think
i swear to you it's not a game you have
ever heard of but oh okay
i am in i am in desperate pain it is a
terrible video game uh
i yeah i i just i just finished it last
night and i'm i was gonna write the
review today and then i just decided i
need a break from thinking about this
game and so i'm going to write it
tomorrow but
legends
this is at least as bad as nerf legends
it's somewhere around there it
it's so bad dude it is i cannot talk
about it without giving away what game
it is but okay crossfire x multiplayer
was a two
right yes and then crossfire was a three
yeah nerf legends was that a four or
three
their reflections was also a two
oh it was that bad okay yeah so this one
two two is the lowest i've ever gone i'm
thinking it'll probably be a two or
three i i don't see it going above a
three at the very most it's just i am
sorry i can't really i can't really get
into details but let's just say it's
like you're good it's not just a bad
game because it breaks all the time it's
also the content of the game is like
deeply offensive it's just that's
exactly what you wanted a video game
you're like
and it's awful to play it's so bad man
uh so anyway i've been playing that um
i'm playing star wars lego star wars
that's a little that's gonna be cleanser
oh i love it it's so good i i can't
believe how good that game is it really
feels like a next-gen game
um g-man asks why is ign always giving
travis these trash games i have a
feeling i have a feeling that when ign
feels that a game is going to be bad
this is just my theory please don't like
say that this is true we're just going
to just like speak theory into existence
for you so it happens yeah my theory is
that when they see a game and they think
this game's bad they want to give
somebody who they know is going to give
an honest opinion about it and they know
that hey i don't mind playing bad video
games that much because i kind of i kind
of find it fun it's like it's like you
know a really awful smell
you know or bad movie night yeah
something like that it's it's sort of
interesting um but yeah it's uh
i i messaged one of the guys on the ign
team after i played it for a couple
hours and i was like so
you guys knew this game was gonna be bad
when you gave it to me didn't you and
his response was i don't know what
you're talking about and then that gif
of the monkey going
you know
that monkey the monkey puppet like
looking over the side though so i was
just like this guy i was set up but
anyway um that's what i've been doing
how are you what are you up to
uh yeah i am level 125 in elden ring of
about 90 hours uh i'm working on
becoming king of the north which if
you've played you know kind of where i'm
at that makes sense to some people uh
that game just keeps blowing me away
though um
every time you think you're seeing a
little more every little puzzle i was
lost in a catacombs for like an hour
trying to figure out where to go and
it's just the little puzzles in there
you think you've seen them all and once
again
you haven't
so no it's it's
i just i'm playing every moment i can i
even streamed it for literally two hours
right before the podcast just to sneak
some in
so no i'm i don't know how much more i
have left i'm guessing i might be
two-thirds through it from everybody
saying it's about 120 hours or so but
no it's one of those where i'm kind of
trying to stretch it out as much as
possible
so i don't
actually
what
are our guests well we're going to
introduce her really quickly because she
has changed her camera and i can't keep
a straight face so let's get our
introduction in and we will get going
here elderly has been fun i've been
raiding a lot no no that was hilarious
i'm gonna have to ask about that in a
second okay okay hold on
all right so let's introduce you because
now i've been i broke i broke broke the
fourth wall all right welcome to the
last word episode number 192 as we get
farther into the season and the
difficulties cranked up to 11 we are
faced with a couple of acute issues the
scientists of gambit got some wires
crossed and the grand master door opened
up to throw everything and the kitchen
sink at guardians who wanted to
challenge
our guest tonight is a veteran of level
destiny content but that's no surprise
as the gaming journey started many years
ago with the likes of mario mortal
kombat and final fantasy bungie made the
first shooter she played and fittingly
now the one that she's hooked on for
life but it isn't just her fps skills
that will keep you around it's the joy
she brings to her streams and those
around her just jump in her chat for
five minutes and you're likely to put a
smile on your face and likely be
laughing out loud for any number of
reasons despite whatever is being talked
about on stream at the moment while she
may be dressed like a disney princess at
times is not likely her chat that would
give her a g movie rating so let's
welcome a lady who hails from the land
of a thousand lakes and twitch partner
and member of last rights certified
goofball who also got secret access
access to the dating side of twitch the
one the only tiddly how are you doing
that is literally the best intro i've
ever had and i'm totally stealing it
that is totally fine
you are allowed to use that part of the
audio for anything youtube thank you so
much i'm doing great how are you guys
doing
we are
we are good
excellent i'm excited to laugh and have
sore cheeks by the end of this show
seriously like you i jumped into your
stream a couple times
randomly and one of them
i think it was earlier this week i don't
know what you were doing but it was the
weirdest topic of conversation and i was
just like what did i walk into
i mean i feel like often it sounds like
you're um things get off the rails but
it's very oh absolutely i think that
that's actually the best way to stream
i find that the best way to stream is
literally just pride of trying to
provoke reaction because if you're and i
feel like that's why my community and my
chat tends to be so interactive because
i i do anything i can
to like rile them up so i'll you know be
sassy with them and i'll bring up weird
topics and they'd be like what are we
talking about but it does it does kind
of come up with these kind of like what
is going on here type moments people
when people really first come into this
stream yeah then they're like what is
going on here but it's nice because i
think
it kind of means that the community sort
of self-selects right so you know the
people who really like that will stay
and the people who don't leave and you
know find somewhere that they'd rather
be so that's great for me yeah
well travis would you like to get this
started
yeah if i could um so
you in uh ibontas intro and in the the
survey you filled out you talk about how
your first shooter was a bungie shooter
can you talk about how you you fell in
love with uh bungie shooters and your
kind of uh
your trajectory toward discovering
destiny eventually
yeah i know it's interesting i think i
think that
i don't know and i don't know why but i
feel like i'm always attracted to the
video games because i have friends or
people that i know that are playing them
and so for me halo reach was my first
first person shooter i've been playing
other types of games before that but
um my sister actually funnily enough was
really into the halo franchise and um it
just turned out that halo reach was the
game that was out at that particular
time
and so i picked it up so i could play
with her online because we were you know
we weren't living with each other
anymore so it was a way first kind of
connect and um hang out with each other
online and you know i know a lot of
people did that during coven and stuff
like that it's a nice way to kind of
socially connect with people long
distance um but you know yeah we would
just log on go into big team battle get
a warthog she'd be driving around and
i'm like i get the gun and i'm like in
the back like shooting people if you'd
be hollering all over the place like i
mean we had so much fun i think
uh yeah but definitely i think that halo
was kind of where i kind of fell in love
with first person shooters um i really
liked
a lot of the objective oriented type um
type type maps and stuff like that like
i liked um i always went for the hammer
first in halo reach um i did play call
of duty also and i played a little bit
of kill confirm but didn't get as much
into the
um the shooter there i think that for me
the bungee shooters the time to kill
tends to be a little higher so it gives
you a little more reaction time it tends
to be a little more accessible and and
for me that's more fun cause i'm in it
i'm in it to like go in and be goofy and
have fun nice so also kind of sad that
dusty doesn't really have any vehicle
pvp maps currently i know there was one
one
that was that was not very successful
but i mean it was supposed to be part of
their formula and i think it's actually
part of the um
the the code that they had that didn't
really translate over because i know
destiny destiny has some of the blam
code in it doesn't it do either of you
guys know the
story there the the blam is the engine
that halo was built on and that they
only got rid of they only got rid of
blam with halo infinite they were using
it all the way from halo 5 that evolved
through to halo uh five guardians that
wasn't proprietary like when they sold
uh and they sold halo no i think they
kept they kept part of the blam uh
engine in destiny if i'm not mistaken
i'm sure somebody will correct me on
this
or whatever it is that they call it now
yeah i think it ended up some of that
ended up becoming part of a part of
tiger or at least some of the people who
worked on it were there but uh
that the the vehicle part is like a part
of the blam engine that
i i feel like never really translated to
destiny for some reason it really gave
up way too quick in my opinion i feel
like they could have developed it and
they were just like nah let's just drop
all the big maps and just never talk
about vehicles again
it's kind of sad because the vehicles
were really really fun in halo reach
they were so much for sure
and they really were not fun in destiny
one there was literally one map you
could have you could get in the vehicles
in that one map and it didn't really
benefit you that much strategically so
it wasn't yeah i think everyone hates
those maps and the vehicles were gone
yeah which is weird because there were
there was that one on the moon i think
is the one you're talking about first
one yeah yeah
then they added one on the mars yeah
exactly and they took that one away the
mars one came later i think that was
with the third dlc or something but they
they removed it they were like whatever
yeah
but there definitely is a similarity in
terms of the sort of halo gun feel and
the gunfield and destiny and i think
that's one of the reasons why the game
is addictive is that sort of like the
way that the the guns feel to to play
with um their their individual like they
the sound that they make is interesting
you know i think that there's there's no
shooter that i've ever picked up that
plays as fun as destiny in terms of gun
play um but i think that halo definitely
you could like i think that sort of my
enjoyment of halo and how that felt
definitely translates to how some of the
reasons i really enjoy destiny also did
you check out the new halo the halo
infinite game at all i haven't i haven't
actually there's like just way too much
to do in destiny right now
when are we supposed to find time for
that but yeah is it good do you like
halo infinite weirdly has been a uh a
great outlet for us pvp mains who have
sort of been scorned for a while yeah
yeah yeah for sure so that but as a pve
main which you are you probably just
have so much to do that you're oh i'm
having a great time game isn't a great
place absolutely
we hurt and over on the pvp side i
understand i'm so sorry i definitely
have some friends that are pvp players
and i know that they've kind of promised
in some of the 12 that they're going to
you know renew focus add new maps um
yeah in the meantime
in the meantime we get to play around
with camp but yay
yeah oh yeah
love that we'll get to that later sure
an experience but yeah we'll get to that
a little bit um but i want to kind of
touch on just some of the games even
before shooters that you've enjoyed sure
yeah i mean obviously some old school
ones and i know
even just some ogs that we all know it's
like what are your
just like favorite games obviously you
know halo gotcha shooters destiny you
can't stop playing for thousands of
hours or whatever like all of us but
before that or even like mixed in what
are your other games that you've like
you know if you had top five games like
where where are those in your history of
things that you've got
oh
that's a really good question um number
one's destiny obviously well yeah number
one destiny i i i think that it's always
wise so you don't become a burnt out
angry person on destiny reddit and
twitter to have an alternate game to
play when when you know the season has a
lull and before the new content comes
out so i usually reach for i usually
reach for overwatch
funnily enough because overwatch is one
of those overwatch is a game where it's
a first person shooter but then all of
the characters already have their own
builds and their own weapons and none of
that changes you don't have to grind any
of it so it doesn't take any any work to
get back into it so overwatch tends to
be my game that i play consistently when
destiny has lulls um but i'm playing
tiny tina's right now and really
enjoying that that's super fun nice um i
reviewed that for ign oh fantastic yeah
no i'm really really enjoying it it's
very very fun um when i can kind of like
fit the time in to do that um so i'm
enjoying that right now um but you know
i like your class i started with a
berserker and then i just unlocked the
um the clawbringer i believe
except for my second one
yeah you can compare it together
i think speaking of
well sorry yeah go ahead
i said speaking of dnd oh dnd right i
know it all kind of nicely connects
doesn't it um but yeah no i heard that
the companion build is really strong so
i think for my next playthrough i'm
probably gonna do that but i'm still
working on my first playthrough kind of
in conjunction with like playing destiny
right now so that's kind of fun right i
mean i like like playing overcooked have
you ever played over character with
friends it's crazy you can make it you
can also burn burn bridges at the same
time
yes
absolutely i like to murder people with
vegetables in overcooked that's my
favorite thing good sounds like a mrs
doubtfire quote just slightly wrong but
again
i do it's very fun
a lot of my friends won't play it with
me anymore i don't know why but yeah i
know
i know why yeah
no but um we were actually talking a
little bit before the show and you said
tiny tina's and then dungeons dragons so
i'm just going to t-ball this one up for
travis um you said yeah we have played d
and d kind of for the first time getting
into it so i wanted to yeah let travis
kind of pick your brain on your
experiences there
well no it sounds like you've played d d
extensively right is that my
understanding oh no no no this is my
first year i just started like oh this
year
yeah no but i i hopped in
i am a newbie but i did hop in a game
that's been going on for five years so
it's a very long existing game that's
tough
unless they gave you a really powerful
character they did they started i
started out at level 11 and now i'm
level 13. wow so you're already
unkillable at the start
assuming you're playing 5e right
i don't know what that is
but
you guys don't know what that is i do
right now
right
so there's lots of different versions of
dungeons and dragons over the years and
5e is the current edition it's called
i'm assuming fifth edition
yeah no my my uh my dm is just has all
of the current stuff he has like the
monster book he has like the critical
cards which he won't let us use anymore
because we had we had we had one guy
roll a critical fail and pull a critical
fail card and he lost one intelligence
permanently and no one will let it go
everyone is like ha ha go mar you're
dumb now you lost an intelligent pointer
permanently so we remove we don't do
critical hit cards anymore but he's got
like that he has this little like
um
basement area and like whenever there's
a a new monster that comes up he'll like
go back there and then you know bring
out this new monster and just that he's
spent hours are you doing it on zoom or
are you in person oh no we do it in
person yeah
beautiful beautiful yeah i hate doing
rpgs over over virtual it just doesn't
have the same impact i think um
but yeah uh somebody
so uh before the show for the for those
in chat who missed this i was talking
about my history as a game master and
how that i don't i don't play dungeons
and dragons but i play lots of other
tabletop rpgs and tiddlywinks said
uh there are other rpgs and i was like
oh boy we're about to get into it so
yeah
everywhere oh yeah so yeah
i got this bundle from tinytina and it
has
uh two two role-playing books included
in it yes and i haven't looked at this
so there is uh bunkers and badasses is a
real tabletop rpg that you can which is
kind of interesting right so you could
actually do that yeah i think i'm gonna
get into my dm it's based off of the
video game obviously but um yeah that i
i own that one i i probably own like
over 50 tabletop rpgs i actually used to
review them uh back in the day oh my
gosh
dungeons and
dragons the way i think about it
dungeons and dragons is sort of like a
good starting point and when most people
think of tabletop rpgs they think of d d
but it's sort of the starting point in
my opinion it's like
you know it's it's like okay casual you
know not really but casual nerd
the tabletop oh just dungeons and
dragons i've got 50 tabletop games you
haven't even seen my table it's
absolutely not something people brag
about it's going to be i know i know i
know a very specific circle that you can
flex in if you're talking about correct
okay
it's not you're just
walking to the bar you're like
hey girl
you want to see my table top games
hey you know what you joke but you would
be surprised how much of uh a foot in
the door that was with my current
girlfriend well that's that's just on my
own
you do you have to find the right one
although i have to say a
rabbit hole i didn't know that i would
get into is the dice the dice are so
pretty and i like anything that's shiny
and oh my gosh they're they're expensive
but they're so pretty so i'm super yeah
yeah i can't be basic but some of my
friends have like over 200 dice and they
bring them over every time we play rpgs
and i'm like you know you're not going
to need any of those right and they're
just like but i want them here
yeah i want to show them off and they're
always talking about it it's made of
meteor rock and it was sculpted by blind
nuns
right
um g-man i'm not an elitist on tabletop
rpgs i simply
you know d d is everyone's first and i
respect it a ton i just think that you
can only play d d for so long before you
kind of want something different because
dd is pretty generic let's be honest
it's kind of then they made a star wars
game and you had to leave dnd behind
they made a star wars rpg which is far
superior uh and then there's also i just
love indie rpgs there's so many great
rpgs out there made by small teams then
you can play them and just be like blown
away
this is gonna be difficult you can pick
one outside of dnd
to recommend only one to recommend to
someone yes so you're like all right
you've played a lot i need one more not
your list of 50 one
it would depend on what type of player
they are because there's some players
that are really into the stat part the
the board game part of d and if you're
into that you probably want a game
that's a little bit more like chunky you
know it has more like numbers and math
and like strategy on like you doing
stuff but the type of rpgs i like are
really the story rpgs and so if you're
really into like the storytelling part
then i have a million recommendations
but the one i would give a shout out to
because it's uh kind of the the one that
i've been obsessed with for like the
past six months or so is um this game
called legend of the five rings it's a
uh like old uh feudal japan dynastic
china samurai role-playing game
yeah right no he would love it he would
love it it's so great because it's like
basically the entire game is set up for
like your character has like desires and
personal things that they want but they
can't do it because they're just like a
stoic samurai who's sworn to basically
like sacrifice themselves for the good
of the empire and like it's all that
like drama and like putting aside your
personal wants so that you can do your
your duty and your obligation and it
just has so much beautiful storytelling
drama so if i'm really going heavy nerd
that's the one i would recommend for
people i have a question for you too how
would you describe yourself as a dm like
what's your style yeah um yeah i'm
pretty
do you do like voices and characters or
you yeah do you like it you like do the
accents and like you know okay what's a
couple characters i want to hear a
couple of yeah yeah i want to joke about
example your favorite character
yeah yeah i know somebody in the
comments said i'm so alive when
discussing this you should see me
playing as a game master i'm like really
really into it it's kind of disgusting
so if any of you guys are in san
francisco by the way anybody in the
comments section if you're ever in sf
you're welcome at my table that's a real
offer i will actually let you come play
with me um but anyway uh yeah as a as a
as a gm i'm uh i i i say this with total
sincerity and not as a brag but i think
i'm like one of the one of the goats of
game mastering to be honest and like
it's like really really very honest yes
i mean
you know humility i i just honestly i
just honestly think i've i've uh
i i'm really like unique so i i write my
own stories i put in like a ton of
effort uh you know do characters i even
make music for some of my campaigns so
like i'll make like themes for certain
characters i go super hard on this you
guys okay so you have all this and time
invested in the story you've created we
will eventually get there and we'll get
back to destiny i promise
you you you love these characters you
created them you're so creative and
original and unique and amazing and an
amazing gm so what happens if one of
your players murders just up and murders
one of the characters you've created
which is not one of the characters i've
created oh that's yeah like i have no
attachment
yeah no i i have total uh attachment or
no attachment to my characters or i
actually think um
characters dying can be like great
storytelling in rpgs but it kind of just
even if it's unplanned
you're able to kind of like maneuver
around dinner
what do you do i i don't i'm actually
not one of i'm not one of those gm's who
like railroads people or creates a path
that i expect you to follow i'm very
much more open-ended like i have
what i what i'll do is i'll create like
a timeline of what would happen if the
player characters weren't there at all
and then i let them sort of impact that
right and so they're they have the total
uh independence to sort of like do
whatever they want this is getting super
off track and i love it but uh we should
probably we can go back to that
just so you guys know when i when i get
into video games i i kind of i approach
it from this like
this like like this kind of perspective
it's the reason i'm so into destiny to
be honest it's kind of the same thing
it's rpg mechanics and storytelling and
all the stuff we love about games so
well for our guest tiddly and try and
swing this back around a little bit here
chat for um
do you have any accents that you are
either good at or proud of
that's one of my moderators and they're
trying to bait me
um my all of my accents inevitably sound
like mrs dalfoyer or a horrible russian
accent so beautiful no please
no no
what is your character
tell us your level 13 character what are
you playing in 5e i am um i'm basically
a tank so i i told my i told my dm that
i wanted to be a character that was
similar to kind of a titan because
that's my favorite character
bring it back you know because i'm a
titan so i was like i want to be a tanky
character um and retrospect i kind of
wish i picked a character with magic
because magic is really really fun but
basically i've got like
more hit points than any other character
in my in my game so i basically get in
the middle of it and then just um but my
character essentially she's um
she's a mercenary but she was um i kind
of like she was kind of trained in the
circus she ran away to the circus when
she was little and so she's an acrobatic
fighter essentially so she uses double
blades
from psychonauts
actually i modeled her after jackie chan
i was thinking like you know but also
but kind of like more with the japanese
like hakuma like she wears like uh this
is sort of like voluminous pants to hide
her movements when she's being acrobatic
and fighting and so every time she slays
a foe she attaches another colorful uh
colorful like string to her pants and so
when she's when she's like fighting it's
like she's dancing because she's like
moving quickly and like beautiful
yeah so that's kind of you had art
commissioned of her yet i haven't i
haven't she's very cool though she's
also very gay she's she's a lesbian i
haven't engaged her in any romantic
liaisons yet but i'm hoping to do so in
the future beautiful yeah unexplored
territory yeah that's that's the next
step on nerd dummies you get you get you
pay for art done of your character and
that's how you know you've really gone
too far that is really fun i like
commissioning art for my channel so i
could see where that would be really fun
put that on your to-do list apparently
well
30 minutes in or so i warned you man i
warned you as soon as dnd came up i knew
i knew i knew it was gonna be trouble we
literally said that before the podcast i
was like oh can worms everywhere it
happened
all good but
we all have actually been playing this
destiny thing every so often we do that
in between
elden ring and d d and all these other
things that we tend to i'm sorry star
wars games too star wars i heard star
wars lego is amazing by the way star
wars lego actually looks really really
cool i thought it was i think it really
is like way better than i thought it was
going to be i've heard people are like
this thing has like so much more like
i've heard it's a much bigger game than
anybody expected i mean i figured with
the nine movies it was going to cover a
lot but they could do it it might be
longer than eldon ring honestly i doubt
that
no dude if you saw it you'd be like
maybe like it might be like the the
sheer undercover
it might be more than 100 hours to be
honest with you because just looking at
the map you it's got open world you can
travel between like 50 different planets
dude like it's crazy
300 plus characters i'm honestly like i
i wouldn't be surprised if people had
longer play times than eldon ring on
this one it's so i guess if you're
trying to collect every little 100 or
something it might take a little crazy
one yeah but
for sure so this week in the world of
destiny since i may as well uh have a
very horrible segue to get us over there
um but thank you to lee for joining us i
appreciate it um we know you are in fact
a titan so you're actually since cognito
is not here we have a titan podcast all
three of us type names right yes let's
go
so what is team mac right we must all be
on t-maxx team mech
team monster or mac what are you
obviously team mac i feel like yeah
unfortunately okay here's my here's my
hot take on the voting okay so
team mec ostensively better for titans i
mean look look yeah look at how the high
tide looks really good it's going to
look really good for the titan uh rocket
boots obviously the pants look like
titan rocket boots uh it's awesome it's
awesome however
the hunter cloak for the monsters is
definitely the best item in the monster
set so i think all of the hunters in
destiny are gonna vote for the monsters
all of the titans are going to vote for
the max i have no idea what the warlocks
are going to do wild card there they're
the decision makers there are so
many hunter mains in the game there is
no way mex are going to win 100 going to
go to monsters really
it's all those hunter mains the dirty
hunter mains they're going to vote for
the monsters that's what's happening
i tend to agree with you but i think
warlocks might go the other way i think
i see the warlocks of the wild card they
could they could shift it one way or the
other they could change it yeah i did
want to take a second fork boy with the
50 super chat a while ago thank you very
much sorry i'm late but wanted to say
thanks to cog even though he's not here
uh for helping him get into the ilp clan
and also doing a raid with the clan was
awesome time also wanted to give a shout
out to a random person who hit 4 million
damage on the rogue fight somebody's
putting in some more if you're doing a
damage check at 4 million damage
i don't know how you checked that unless
he had like this much health and died
but
that's an impressive damage number for
sure
uh but anyway sorry i had to shout that
one out that was way too big
that's a chunk of cash yeah
um but yeah so titan for sure favorite
exotic and subclass
ooh
well i am actually loving the new titan
uh sunspot exotic
on the lurleen i i know it was nerfed
right um but i still really really enjoy
it i was running void titan so i mostly
i mostly swap between void titan um
the the kapow arc
uh chess piece i love that that was so
much fun so i i do well i'm gonna guess
that those are the three i do but mostly
i've been running um
i've been running the sunspot exotic
even though gundart is still really
really fun i feel really tanky i run it
in pve i know that it's been moderately
problematic in pvp and i think it's kind
of unfortunate they nerfed it because it
sounds like the nerfs came kind of from
the pvc pvp side of things and less from
the pve side of things and i know that
it's kind of unfortunate what that
happens in destiny it works the other
way around like sometimes stuff is
nerfed because it's too strong on pve
and it affects pvp negatively but i
think in this particular case i'm a
little sad that they nerfed it but it's
still it still feels really good like
i'm still really really enjoying like
sunspot the sunspot build right now nice
i know it just depends
like hey i know it supposedly got nerfed
but you should still use it because
apparently it's still very good so
you're not alone it's so tanky it's so
good and i always i usually forget to
put my barricade down you know like i'm
not i'm really sad when it takes it you
know it's okay no i'm not mad about it
yeah um i don't know travis what do you
mean typically for your subclass
these days you kind of have to do void
right so that's been my i'm doing bubble
tight so which i guess that would be
void i was gonna say yeah void is a big
one but i was gonna say i guess do you
want arc 2.0 for your titan or do you
want solar 3.0 for your titan sooner
um either of you by the way i i think
solar needs more of a rework personally
because arc is usable like you can do
the uh
the what do you call it um
the uh
i'm i'm blanking on the middle tree
yeah curious of the falling star thunder
crash and uh that's pretty good i mean
that's what i've been using for for
damage on rolk so
um yeah but but the solar i just there's
really not a lot of use cases for it and
i think it really needs an overhaul
especially the uh
the hammer the middle one the big sludge
the middle tree yeah no one uses the big
hammer the big hammer is the meme
although people do use we're using the
mini hammers for some really interesting
low man stuff
you know
yeah the little melee builds yeah the
mini hammers the mini hammer builds
without god caress or anything like that
yeah i mean i i don't i don't do that
but i know that like once you punch worm
god uh mini hammers like all that stuff
has been really interesting in terms of
breaking the game and i always find it
interesting when people break the game
and do cool things so
um but yeah i personally disagree i kind
of want arc to get buffed i think solar
is maybe one of the more used um across
the board if i'm not talking selfishly
titan wise because i mean i kind of
agree with you in terms of titan wise
but i feel like across the board solars
has more utility currently
especially with wow with warlock well in
particular but um but also i think what
i'm most looking forward to in in terms
of the 3.0 classes is the animations
because we were talking about that today
like i love when i'm when i'm playing on
a void titan i love putting my barricade
out because it's just like chunk it's
like so fun and then i that the shield
throw you're just like it's like a
frisbee you're like
you know like i i love that i love i
think that it's gonna be really fun um
seeing sort of like upgraded animations
it makes the playing more fun when they
when they have those i'm curious to see
what those are and also i really really
really really want them to add the
synaptic spear that's in the psyops
battlegrounds to the ark 3.0 that'll be
so much fun that is such a fun weapon
so much fun they had mentioned like
kevin giannis had mentioned something
about that of kind of the way the
synaptic sphere has the bigger jumps and
like the double blinks like that might
have been like a little tease of
something that might be coming right
right this could be yeah yeah verbs
because they said like because we had
the verbs of
volatile and all those are the words
that defined void and i've been trying
to think through arc and solar so like
if arc is right
you know
fast a bad choice of words i'm sure they
would have but like blink or anything of
that nature and the solar is going to
have burning and exploding and healing
and i'm kind of wondering what the six
words they use for the other two are
going to be shout out real quick to mri
gamer
love you titty
but trev be happy i wasn't in chat last
week as your destiny pvp elitist i would
have put you in your place love you all
ibantas keep up the lone player struggle
there we go
it's good to have a little balance on
the podcast we got travis is a great way
to round out and bring different
perspectives that's why the three of us
tend to make things interesting and the
guest
just figures out who they're gonna lean
on if it's talking about picky food i
lose usually but that's that's the whole
thing
um but yeah it's like i'm very curious
what they do if solar leans into healing
a bit more or something and we get
because we have the well uh and then we
have our sunspots
hunters don't really have anything and
if they get something like that that'll
really kind of mix things up
i mean i i see it as sort of the problem
with the exotic laves this season in
terms of defining that particular
burn right so like the obviously the the
titan one is the bubble which is kind of
connected to sort of like the protection
the like the you know the whole idea
identity of void you know the the solar
one you know the what is it the um
the warlock when it's connected to
healing and solar right which makes
sense that's all connected to like like
you know like wells and healing nades
all that stuff and then and then the
hunter one is what
same light yeah it's like a yeah and
you're just like launcher that's all it
is you're just okay so i i think that
bungie may be having a hard time kind of
pinpointing that arc identity i think
that's like demonstrated in sort of the
the sort of weak well i mean i don't i
don't know i know that they buffed the
graves recently i don't know how good
they are but i've heard that they're
just generally not super exciting but i
feel like of of the three the hunter the
hunter grape is the least exciting
because it's arc and because they don't
know what to do with it right because
they don't have an identity for the arc
yeah that actually makes a lot of sense
because
yeah it's like when you think about arc
you might have movement you might have
chain is the only thing i've heard them
like chain lighting for like wrist
runner and other stuff but and then
you've got lightning with thunderlord
and stuff of that nature but yeah when
you put when you get to the glaives
you're going you literally do what a
grenade launcher does that's it yeah
right right
that's that's not fun
yeah but they
when you said they buffed them they look
took the charge from all glaives from
six to four for the charge and you know
yeah the exotics are
still not no they're not worth your
exotic slot yeah they're definitely not
with your random pulling your hair out
of wellspring because if you go through
wellspring and you get all of your
frames which i've done and i don't have
the hunter glaive that's the only one i
didn't get i don't know if i'm ever
gonna go get it
unless they make that thing like the god
pokey stick i'm like probably no it is
it's i think it's moderately unfortunate
because i always think that um bungie
does best when they introduce something
overpowered and then nerf it later and i
think that they really had a miss here
with the glaives because the glades are
a really fun idea they're a completely
new type of weapon and they it to
introduce them not in an overpowered or
like super super like power fantasy way
is really unfortunate because i think
that like people aren't using them
oh yeah and i think buffing them later
they're kind of missing that moment yeah
well they just nerfed suppression too
yeah so i mean paul feel like they they
were overpowered at the beginning though
that for those first couple weeks with
the suppression i mean they had to turn
it off that's true the hunter the hunter
invisibility
glaive not not necessarily the exotic
one but just like the regular glade with
invisibility built but that's more so
that's more so like the um the artifact
mods
you know well that was the first time
um shout out to tassie because he said
this just
it was the idea that they've never
nerfed the artifact mods because they're
meant to be temporary they're meant to
be strong because they have a short
lifespan even
you know even in six months they let us
have god tier linear fusion rifles for
six months long but this suppression
thing's a little bit too strong and i
don't know if they were just like people
are gonna run all over gm's or whatever
it was but
no it was really weird for them to
actually nerf those artifact mods
because right is that the first time
they've actually reached in and changed
them i think so maybe you'll like it i
feel like because i mean we've had
god-tier grenade launchers
then we had the crazy particle
deconstruction like fusion rifles and
linears were just six months of that's
the only thing you should use and then
we get glaze feel kind of good for just
a bit and then like chopped off at the
knees so
i don't even use any of the glaive
artifact mods honestly i think they're
just kind of wasted currently
but
i don't know
[Music]
are you a glade
now that i think about it i haven't no i
mean i play pvp the glade was never
going to be my champion have you watched
people try and like glaive each other
it's hilarious to watch i won't even
kill them if they're both going out i'm
just gonna sit back and let it happen
i've not even seen two people bring
glaives into pvp to be honest with you
so everything oh my my friend shake use
this out and i'm going
what
i totally forget that they're in there
sometimes in pvp and then you get like
kind of stun locked almost like an elden
ring you get the triple shot and you're
down i'm going
that's really weird i didn't think
anybody but
but there was part of the iron banner
quest line that said
blaze or snipers and there were people
running around with hunter invades doing
glaives and doing pokey sticks on all
your banner last time oh even me as a
titan because i'm not gonna claim to be
a great sniper and it depends on the map
on if i'm gonna have a shot i got my 10
kills all of them with a glaive on that
one i just you know found a little
couple close quarters areas and if you
do get the one tooth if you start that
combo and you're close you can get a one
two three generally because they can't
seem to really it kind of does almost
lock him in place a little bit when you
get that going i got my 10 kills that
actually that was probably the easier
part of the quest for me once i just got
a decent map to do it with surprisingly
i thought that was gonna suck and then
all of a sudden i was like
well i'm not the best sniper i'm
mediocre at best but that was way easier
than sniping for 10.
[Music]
so the big thing that unlocked this week
was grand master nightfalls and i saw
you playing some of those tiddly so
the big controversy
was the patch notes
was the acute modifier which a couple
weeks ago they're like hey grandmasters
or all the mod all the nightfalls have
this acute modifier 25 percent
more outgoing damage but you have 50
more going in all the different levels
master normal hero all those things but
you get a burn on nightfalls kind of
lets you have a little more fun but
they're like except in big bold black
letters
grand masters pride masters now as many
people as look over the twab
we're gonna go a little tinfoil hat i
guess here as many people as probably
look at review edit maybe the twab it
can't just be like the community manager
other people have to put the pieces in
there that was big bold black like big
bold letters
and then they're like nope never mind
switch that that was totally meant to be
there and then it's because we took out
the other modifiers even on grand
masters okay but i hope you enjoy
that was like the big controversy so i
wanted to get your thoughts on that one
and then also since you've played some
this week uh how are they feeling as
well so first off what did you think of
what happened with the buff were you
worried and also how's it been going
um i
i i'm not mad about it
i mean it's it's possible tin foil hat
theory is correct
um but i think that in terms of the like
high level pve content i've experienced
worse modifiers than the acute modifier
honestly
and you also can build to compensate
like like blasts what was the what was
the melee one where they when one hit
killed you with the melees oh um um i
know what you're talking about i can't i
can't remember that one that one was
horrible it was like no radar and
melee's like are really strong i know
what to do
the thorn questline we had to do that
like that strike and then like you know
at the end of it like there's just all
the thralls that one hit kill you with
that modifier anyway that one was
horrible i uh the cute damage
it's awful but if you're in a gm you're
gonna get one hit by things anyway and i
think that you're using hardcover most
of the time anyway and other strats so i
don't think it's a huge problem i really
don't i'm not mad about it it does mean
that you are sacrificing flats
to compensate for damage you know so
basically absolutely apparently so our
our friend eladio um antarctic um
wildlife did some testing and apparently
you need to have two sniper resist mods
in order to not die one hit kill from
the snipers yeah i saw i saw a video if
somebody were bugged
yes
those scores
those those scorn those scorn raiders in
particular they're just absolutely nasty
um but you know i think that you just
adjust your build
and go with it i think that i'm not
super mad about it and in terms of like
playing the gm's um i'm still working on
finishing
finishing guilding my conquer this this
time around um but actually it's it's
it's just really really fun um i think
it's really fun that they have there's
two
new gm's this season and i think with
the last one was what proving grounds
was the last new one that came out i
think
um but it's it's really great because i
i mean and i i know it's tough because
there's not a lot of new pvp stuff but
when you get two new gm's in a season
that is actually super super fun um
and we're so those are those are the
ones that i'm working on right now i'm
gonna probably be doing those on stream
tomorrow morning um i was gonna ask if
you'd actually done because i've heard
the light blade is
yeah easily yeah i haven't tried that
one yet yeah i've heard it's really
really bad i think there's no cover in
the boss room um strategically i've
heard that like a lot of hunter invades
is really good in the boss room um i've
been watching some people play it and
i'm actually working on redoing my my
hunter build i'm probably gonna run it
on hunter which is actually i feel
really guilty but i've been running
hunter invest so much it's just void
hunter and this is so strong no i mean
i've been running that a lot in gms i
feel like i'm cheating on my favorite
character yeah i was watching fallout a
bit earlier and they were working
through
as well that was the one he's struggling
with but he was
running invis most of the time i think
they had one stasis warlock i don't know
if the other hunter was in those two but
invis is
invis is like the brutal is the way to
kind of get around the brutality get for
a res and those types of things it seems
like a very clutch important piece of
ability yeah absolutely i think part of
it is just sort of and budgie's talked
about this before it's sort of the way
that they design they do level design on
whether it's strikes or story missions
they tend to do it in the linear fashion
where you start at one place and you
advance through an area with cover um
where ads are advancing at you from the
other direction and i think that they
they moved away from that i think i
can't remember what season they moved
away from that and then they were like
oh we're now we're going back to that
we're going back to sort of that linear
design and i find that the
the two new strikes or the two new gm's
play very much in sort of that linear
old-fashioned traditional bungee style
you know how this works um except for
the boss rooms because the boss the boss
room and the light blade strike i think
that's the challenge and why invis is so
strong is because there's there's no
good cover you don't have to keep on
moving yeah um
you know and in order to survive but um
but the rest of the rest of you know my
experience has been kind of just like oh
it's it's kind of like what you're used
to it's kind of the same thing yeah
yeah
so i wanted to ask a question because i
saw it on twitter as well um
and you travis me can all throw in when
it comes to the accessibility of grand
masters
do you feel like they're in a good place
do you feel like the
time commitment in a season is
like a good requirement to be able to
access them do you feel like they could
be a lower level even though contest is
still there it doesn't really matter
what level you are i'll just kind of get
you curious because i saw something
tweet and i replied and little chain was
going so i just kind of wanted to get
anybody in chat can jump into do you
think
the 1575 requirement to enter a gm is in
a good place or could you do
1550 but just do contest in the same
level of difficulty difference
anybody
i'll go ahead i've been talking for a
lot a lot so
uh yeah i guess um i don't really
understand the purpose of the higher
level if they're going to cap you anyway
right like they say you have to be 1575
but you can't be higher than 15.75 and
you're already i think at that level
lower how much lower 20 lower i think it
is it's 15 90 so you're you're 15.
right you're 15 lower no no it's wait no
there's 1600 100 yeah 1600 sorry 60 25
below 25 under 25 below okay that's sort
of in line with what they've done in the
past so
um
most of the time when i don't do
nightfalls grandmaster nightfalls it's
not
even necessarily because i don't want to
do it although i certainly don't want to
do it um but it's really more about that
grind to getting to max power
power is such an irrelevant
number these days especially with like
the artifact of modifying it and there
being really no reason to get to max
power
doesn't really help you in trials in my
experience which is my best use case for
it and then uh really the only reason
they have for you to seek max power
these days is
is for
uh grandmaster and i fall and if you
already don't like that activity
it's a pretty tough sell so i i've never
really understood the purpose of it i i
i
yeah
it's kept me from doing grandmaster
nightfalls when i might have done it in
the past but honestly i'm just i don't
think i'm the target audience for it
it's uh
like hey you want to do an activity
you've done 50 times but this time you
arbitrarily get killed by everything
including drags and stuff it's like all
right cool that sounds super fun
definitely what i want to do in destiny
so um yeah i don't know it's just it's
not my thing maybe i shouldn't talk on
it but uh i really don't understand the
purpose of the 1575 grind i don't think
that's a super fun experience so
how do you i'm curious as a pvp mean how
do you find uh power leveling
do you find it more challenging because
i feel like there's less
less activities accessible to you in
terms of powerfuls and pinnacles maybe
not initially because if you're really
good at pvp and you're hopping in
um competitive right and you're getting
those rank up packages for winning
that's definitely really good but like
what are your thoughts on that like how
is leveling as a pvp mean
i mean even i'm a pvp main meaning that
that's what i do when i get to the end
game but i still play a ton of pve so
okay so leveling has never really been a
problem for me it's more that
if you if you really want to level and
like be there in time for grand master
nightfall you have to do activities you
don't enjoy like you gotta play gambit
you know a couple matches a week and
stuff like that where i've just been
like i'm good i don't wanna do that uh
so uh that's sort of been my problem is
i almost never reach max level because
uh i just to do the stuff that's fun i
don't want to hate destiny and uh if you
want to get to max power sometimes you
got to do stuff that's probably going to
make you hate destiny a little bit more
and so just as a policy over the years i
like to have a positive relationship
with destiny when at all possible so i i
tend to just stick to the stuff that
that is actually
uh fun and try to ignore the uh the
things that are more beneficial but that
that would make me pissed off and uh
grinding strikes grinding gambit that
sort of stuff it's like
i know this isn't going to be fun for me
let's just
let's just accept that i'm not going to
be max power and and
be at peace with that is basically my my
uh because you don't really need it for
trials honestly
six seven power isn't going to affect
you it really is not it's not going to
make you or break you if somebody's at
max power and you're not so yeah just
yeah yeah
for okay so my answer is
it doesn't it doesn't really bother me i
think for me i do enjoy doing uh high
level pve content and so
for me it kind of goes back to why i was
interested like that question you asked
why did you start playing halo reach i
play video games so i can play with my
friends and so if my friends are
interested in doing grand masters then
i'm going to well first of all that's
not where i started my grind this season
i started my grind this season because i
wanted to be able to do uh val disciples
i love reading so when that i was like
okay i need to be ready for val disciple
so i'm gonna like kind of work on that
i'm gonna grind because i want i wanna
play with my friends i want to like play
this raid with my friends so you know
hit that played vow um and then the next
the next kind of marker is oh i have to
be ready to do grand master nightfalls
when they come out with my friends right
so like grinding grinding grinding able
to do gm's and then the next one i'm i'm
like already a little exhausted and i'm
like oh my god i have to get to 1590 to
be able to do master vow with my friends
oh this is kind of a lot but at the same
time i still i'm still motivated to
grind i think i think part of it is
probably unlike unlike you i do enjoy
like the high-level pve stuff and i
think part of it is i have a high
boredom tolerance and it's also probably
why i play destiny a lot because i have
a high level of tolerance of repetitive
activities um you're in the right place
don't say that
you're destroying a certain type of
player you're describing bungie's
favorite type of player i am their
favorite
no i i really do so i but for but
ultimately the motivation for me in
terms of the grind is always friendship
and always playing with playing with
buds and you know i i like i like things
that are hard and i like being able to
like go in there and prove them like and
like like you know if you go into a gm
you're the last person alive you clutch
it up you make that big play you know i
don't get to do that in pvp i don't get
to 1v3 and just be like oh my god i hit
that collat and oh my god i clutched
that up and we won and like that's i
can't do that i know i don't have the
fastest muscles to do that's pv
eel gives me those big gamer moments
that i that i crave and and i enjoy
doing that with my friends so i don't
mind putting in the hours and um you
know doing the grind in order so let me
ask you guys
bungie loves you yeah
uh but let me ask you this
if you got to do the same activities
same level of challenge difficulty and
hero moments but you didn't have to
grind to do it would that be a more
favorable situation
that's a good question and i don't have
a good i don't have a good answer for
that i think i think part of
part of the reason that gm's
are fun is the sort of exclusivity which
comes from people who aren't like that
it is a you're in an exclusive group if
you do put in that much time in order to
get to the level to be able to do them
so i think which is a very
a very streamer you get to play for
absolutely and i i totally get that i
totally get that but um you know i don't
know i definitely see that aspect of it
you know i i would love to play with as
many friends as possible there's
certainly like for even today like there
was somebody in my stream who's like oh
i would love to do a gm with you and
this is somebody who's like consistently
gotten conqueror or somebody who's
consistently um like a really good um
good player um he was like well i've
been playing genji and impact because
i'm bored with destiny and so i'm not
leveled i'm only i'm like six under and
i can't play this gem of the yeah stuff
like that that's really disappointing
yeah exactly yeah that's where i to see
the argument like oh yeah that sucks
like i would love to just pull this
person in i know he it's not that he's a
bad player he's one of the best players
i know he just
didn't care to play the game enough to
get to 1575. or have the time that's
another really good argument is like
what if you just don't have the time to
put in like with with the game reviews
that i do my my gaming hours are pretty
precious to me when my free gaming hours
yeah sure interesting
and i just feel like if you're if your
main goal is to play with your friends
the power grind is actually limiting how
many friends you could play with so um i
i totally get it and i at the risk of
sounding also elitist i understand the
uh the desire to kind of be in that
group of like people who are at that
level you're like oh we can do anything
i'm sure but i understand it like i get
that because there is a certain amount
of satisfaction to be like i did it i'm
standing i did it i made it
okay so i'm i i'll just play devil's
advocate for the joys of chat but it's
also it depends on time like i've
actually been lucky enough this season
to have a very consistent raid group on
tuesdays my titan is
past 1575 so i can do them i just
haven't done them this week yet i've
been hooked on elden ring but
that's what you said is you have that
skilled friend
his only limitation right now is the
time to repeat that treadmill to bump
that number up and that's it and that's
i guess why when you say you know i like
being in that elite club and it's like
are you saying the elite club where i
have more time than you versus i have
more skill than you and that's where it
gets into very interesting because
you're saying he's just as good as you
and you're like hey you guys play
together cool you know better going down
he's a better player than me for sure
and again it's like his limitation is
just the fact
that
time is the limitation and that's where
again
that is why i loved contest raid mode
shout out real quick to iron lords
podcast cog we do miss you as well hi
it's italy the ninja is down but not out
he is in chat thank you sir so he is
watching he is here in the comments
thank you for the 20 super chat
appreciate that uh did he just give
himself 20 yeah i was gonna say well i
was just gonna give you some of that
back though
i i really i really hear you and and i
know
that
like
being at the power level that i'm at is
definitely related to the fact that i
have a lot of privilege in terms of the
amount of time that i can commit to
video game and that is nothing to do
with my actual skill in the game right
um and in terms of accessing the game
like i understand that not everybody can
access that amount of time in order to
you know to get there so
i mean i i think it's an absolutely
valid point i i sort of see both
perspectives
i think the
on the on the alternate perspective in
terms of like in favor of the grind it
it makes the game replayable right it
gives you something to do it gives you
something a goal to kind of shoot for
which is what bungie wants that's why
it's in there right they they and and
honestly i think the game has been i
think destiny's been critiqued in the
past because it because people hit max
or people
got to that ran out of things to do yeah
yeah they ran out of things to do so i
think that's that but that's a conundrum
and it's it's not there's no good answer
right because you're talking about an
engineering problem you're talking at a
problem of optimization because you want
you get to a point
where people can access the content they
want to play
and you have enough grind to keep people
occupied and engaged in the content so
that's an optimal point and has bungie
hit that with the gm's or like like like
i said i'm exhausted
i don't know i think that's a good
question yeah you know i think there
kind of is a is a good answer at least
in my mind from what i what i would hope
that they would achieve is that they
make
they make all of the mandatory content
easily accessible and i think they've
done a great job of that like playing
the raid especially even on day one was
like more accessible than i think
they've it's ever been like they got it
on a saturday they made the grind not
hard
they made it so that you can you can
power boost by doing the uh become
legend version of the story mode uh and
then you can still do nightfalls you
just can't do the grand master versions
and even trials they've opened up a lot
of doors for that as you know regardless
of what you think about that they've
made it so that lots of people can play
that mode now um and even can play it in
solo queue yeah but i think that they
have to make the grind for the hardcore
people who want things to do every day
who want to live in destiny and they
have to give that outlet but they have
to make it optional so that the people
like me who definitely don't have time
for that kind of grind the people with
kids the people with you know uh jobs
and that sort of stuff where they can't
dedicate all of it they they don't they
don't feel like they're missing out they
don't have fomo over it and i feel like
grandmaster nightfall and the master
raid are good examples where
i respect the people who grind it out
but i personally don't feel fomo because
i got to play nightfalls and i got to
play the raid on the normal modes and i
don't feel like i'm missing out a ton so
i actually think destiny is probably in
the best spot it's ever been in terms of
accessibility
and balancing that with the uh the no
lifers who want to just like right spent
live and destiny yeah they're they're
all their gaming they're trying to make
everybody happy right yeah and they are
yeah i think they're doing a pretty damn
good job it's like
perfectly balanced as you said that
balancing scale it's always going to be
moving a little bit back and forth yeah
this person happy is this too easy is
this too hard too much time too little
time right there's just a lot of factors
that go in
yeah and then it also just kind of
depends on
also as we talk about sometimes
is the reward worth the grind that's the
other side that sometimes they hit and
sometimes they don't
so when it comes to grand master
nightfalls when you're
so if you guild your conqueror title
will you keep grinding grandmasters or
is that all you're mostly doing that for
oh i definitely will okay i just like
carries or you just like no i just like
playing them with friends i just think
they're really fun you know i usually i
usually find i usually finish my conquer
um and then after that
i'm sorry i said we found the unicorn
everybody
[Laughter]
no i do i like i like i like just
playing with friends because i'll gild
it with my like sweaty sweaty buddies
right here like really good at the game
and then i'll go back and i'll do it
with my husband and our buddy chris you
know and they're not they're they're
both full-time people they work
full-time it's really hard for them to
reach that 1575 so they're like you know
right there they work you know they
spend the time they need to they get up
there um and then you know we'll i will
go in these night these gm's with them
it took us probably 25 times to finish
glassway uh last season yeah and or two
seasons i can't remember it took us but
i and i did it like
in two tries i did it in three tries
today like so it's it's it's like but
it's it's so much fun like i like i
don't care
i don't care if i'm doing it over and
over if i'm having fun with people and
like that's the challenge i'm enjoying
it i'm having a good time
elden if you like adventure games i
can't recommend eldering enough because
it's like the magnum opus of dark souls
if you ever want like that variety and
you want a challenge
sounds like that could speak to you is
all i'm saying uh shout out to season
ago sorry shout out to blink with the 10
super chat i agree with travis but
travis said it so i'm angry and he
should apologize jk love y'all so yeah
like apologize
and you apologize as well yeah the other
thing i think uh ibontis is uh sorry to
interrupt uh is um you said is the is
the reward worth it and that's another
area where i've kind of
changed to thinking you know in the past
i've said the reward's not worth it like
why would you do nightfall or
grandmaster and i fall but now that i
think about it if the reward were too
good it would make it mandatory and then
you would have that problem where it
needs to be more accessible because if
you put really good stuff behind
grandmaster nightfall then it's like
well now i've got to do it and if i've
got to do it then i've got to grind to
1575 and then i've got to put on all the
time with the mode i don't like and then
it's sort of it sort of forces players
to play mode they don't like and i kind
of feel like they just need to make
those rewards for master uh raid and
grandmaster nightfall just kind of
better a little better than i have to
say they need to figure out something
with trials also because i am really
jonesing after that trials memento and i
don't know if i can find a couple
friends to take me flawlessly this
weekend or not but i really really want
that um you know granted that's a
cosmetic
that does not look good
i have the gambit one that's the only
one i've been managing to get in that
one i saw a clip or twitter or whatever
it was for the net the i guess it was
grand masters or high level nightfall
memento that looks like a traffic code
on one of them it does
the only good one the only good one is
the is the um is definitely the trials
one and okay so but that's a cosmetic
reward right i feel like that doesn't
necessarily make it a must play but
something something that changes the way
the game
works like rock recluse is probably the
best example of that as a pve player i
was so mad at bungie for putting recluse
in a mode that i was not good at so i
had to play that with like find my
sweaty friends to carry me to get me to
get that the best pve gun in the game
locked behind like pvp content i was so
mad about that so i feel like that's an
example of when it it when they when
they put like you're like you were
saying like when they have a reward it's
kind of like a must get and they lock it
behind like a particular activity so you
feel obligated to play that in order to
get that reward that's right trails
memento is not not on the same level as
rock loose i think i mean because it's
cosmetic um but you know
yeah for sure yeah i think i think
that's exactly it
over the time i i used to criticize them
like oh you know why do you go flawless
on trials like obviously i'll do it
because i enjoy playing pvp but i'll
never do grandmaster nightfall because
it's just not good enough and now in
retrospect i'm sort of looking at it
like it's kind of brilliant because it
means that the people who really want
that stuff will
feel like they've got to do it even
though it's only slightly better they're
just kind of but those people are sort
of just looking for reasons to play the
game more right that's pretty true and
the people who the people who just who
just get in and get out
that's right yeah and actually honestly
ibantus all of us all of us are like
that cog is like that i'm like that and
the people that just want to like enjoy
the story mode play the raid and get out
they can do that without feeling like
they're missing out on auton and i think
that's kind of
beautiful and that's what they want they
want that sort of yeah that's why they
started everyone out of the same level
this season yeah yeah for sure yeah and
they could all be happy to get into the
game i'll be happy without getting fomo
you know they let everybody in at the
same level this season bungie wants
people picking up the game and playing
it like they don't want people to stop
the game because of fomo although i have
to say with all of the the i i used so
i'm the kind of person i used to 100
final fantasy games to give you that
kind of idea of the extent that i will
play a game in order for you to see
everything in it
well it takes one to no one oh so anyway
anyway but when destiny introduced these
seasonal titles
seasonal titles that that you know get
archived i lost the interest in doing
everything in the entire game because at
this point i can't it's just over there
certainly are people out there that have
done every single seasonal title
and i just i'm just like well i can't
get it so i'm not going to worry about
finishing everything now i'm just going
to do what i want to do so in one sense
it's a release because you're freed from
the idea obligation of doing everything
but in the other sense like like like
you said i'm like sort of like you know
sort of like the dream player like i'm
i'm interested in doing replayable
content so are they missing out
on people who might do play the game
more because
you know they they're archiving things i
don't know that's yeah that's the
technical limitation like annoyance
balance
legal
i mean we've you know you listen to
hogue which is like you know attorney of
a couple of us know and talk to and
listen to his thoughts about the whole
bungie sun setting content that you've
paid for
most of us did at least you can't get
access to it and there's some weird ways
even towards the end of last season
when like forsaken pack and then the
little campaign was limited but now you
can buy the little piece of forsaken
that remains
yeah
the monetary structure of the game is
still in kind of a weird state sometimes
with what is and isn't in the game
and now is that weird time where we got
an expansion and we got a season but we
lost four seasons worth of stuff to do
all at the same time it does
kind of suck some of the variety out of
the game but then when we get to the
who's playing three of those seasons of
stuff though
but also you take away the
a newer player chance to experience like
if you tail if you tell somebody in
season 19 that might be a pvp season but
you can go through experience witch
queen season the risen season of
redacted and seasoned redacted which are
going to have some cool stories you can
come in and experience all of that
that is actually a good time where we
are right now is the weird moment where
we just lost a lot and now it's a bit
more limited again so when you talk
about the grind and that also depends on
where it's at too is
you talk about like grinding and
grinding and grinding and that's always
the balance of
they did well to get to 1550 for all of
us to get to 1550 was not hard like 1550
for the raid was cake that was
one character you didn't even need to
like go between characters and have all
your bounties i had bounty saved it
helped with your artifact but honestly
everything else was just a bonus
but literally and then they gave you the
15 20 20. so you had three levels to go
that was beautiful boom done easy yeah
so that part's been the best ever but
then as you said you get into the time
of well do i want to do my three strikes
do i want to do my three gambit matches
do i want to do three strip matches and
crucible then do i want to do
preservation for like the fifth time
even though i've done this thing that
takes a while to do
um and you get to these other pieces
they did mention like legend psyops
actually does have a pinnacle drop to it
but it hasn't showed it for like seven
weeks
so honestly when i but like when i was
looking at it was like there's no point
in doing legends
but apparently i didn't know that was
broken even then though it still doesn't
seem totally i think 1550 should still
be match made but we've broken that one
as many times as we need to but it is
this weird
they are
working with like a whole bunch of like
puppet strings and they've got it
decently balanced for a lot of tiers of
players like you you're like i'll play
i'll play hard to stuff i'll play master
raids keep giving me stuff to play the
other person who comes in plays the
story checks out the season four weeks
later i'm gonna go play something else
and they get the pvp a little bit and
that's where it probably needs the most
help is pvp right now and
and hopefully over the course of this
year they mentioned glory playlist and
survival getting a rework in season 19
but again that's nine months away
theoretically so i do i do think
sunsetting is a good a good thing for
the game number one um because i think
it kind of hones down to the content
that bungie wants to focus on and wants
people to experience when they come into
the game but i also think bungie
has kind of gotten a miss in terms of
introducing um new lights into the
content because i think as a new player
it's
very confusing even as a somebody who
has played thousands of hours of this
game i still get very very confused by
it and and imagine just starting
in the bungee universe you know and
trying to understand what's going on
like
talk about overwhelming like i i don't
know and i don't know how like what kind
of fix there would be for that but i
think that i think they're doing a great
job
with um you know making the base game
free with um raising everybody's power
level the same level when the start
season starts i think all that's very
very good at getting new people in you
know but
they need to do a better job of kind of
like
immersing people in the story although
like for returning players they've done
a better job like in the recent recent
seasons and
integrating the story into the game but
i think they could do a better job for
new players yeah this is this is one
area where i don't know if there's a
good solution because yeah
you see it with every other mmo as well
like world of warcraft it's really bad
at it uh you can go and play that
content same with final fantasy 14 you
can play it but like actually trying to
initiate a new player into it is insane
it's just it's so so hard it's like oh
dude i swear to god the game gets so
cool you can play it with me after 60
hours and it's like
you're like
it's just not gonna happen yeah like
that was my barrier of entry i never
made it through the 60 hours with final
fantasy 14 just because it's such a hard
uh barrier of entry to get through and
you really have to love it all that way
so
i i destiny is is probably the worst at
it though because they took away a lot
of that early content and now it just
seems totally disconnected from any of
that story
and it
yeah and it doesn't it doesn't explain
any of its systems super well so i don't
know that there's a good solution
somebody in the in the comments says
that final fantasy 14 does it really
well i totally disagree i i mean i think
they do a better job at explaining the
game because the whole game is there but
in terms of actually getting you caught
up and playing with your friends right
away like it's kind of a joke i i just
you have to play through so much of that
yeah it is i don't know
but
it's two it's two different philosophies
play through it all before you can
join the modern times
or play through none of it and john join
in right away and be completely lost and
i don't know if either of those is
really a great option i think the latter
is actually great i think that there's a
space in the game where you could just
jump into destiny and enjoy the gun play
and enjoy
the power fantasy and enjoy everything
that comes with just
just like
you know
being in that universe you know
i think the reason it's addictive is
sort of your your character right you
have this this character you become
really attached to you you level it up
you give it toys you know you play with
it every day
um you know so that's that's where the
addiction comes from
go ahead sorry i said is your character
a tamagotchi
i have to feed it i have to make sure i
burp it and make sure i change its
poopies you know but but you know what
i'm saying it's like it's like i feel
like that's the addictive quality but if
you can get people into the game and
just enjoy the gunplay enjoy how it
feels to play the game then i think
they're going to be able to i don't
think the story matters at all i think
that like you know give them a little
bit of of the universe and the story but
like who cares about the story let them
just enjoy playing the game and i think
where that comes into play is the pvp
area and i think because pvp
pvp and that's where the pvp work really
really needs to happen and really soon i
think pvp
is the only reason destiny 1 lived as
long as it did i think it extends the
life cycle of the game i think it makes
the seasons more fun i used to just hop
in and i'm not a pvp player i used to
just hop in crucible in quick play and
just hang out with my buddies and talk
and play quick play in destiny 1 and i
don't do that anymore because quick play
is so
not fun at all anymore for me so if they
fix that i think they're gonna that's
it's gonna only help uh returning
players and it's only gonna help the
longevity of the game and it's only
gonna help um new players coming in just
to kind of come in and enjoy
how the game feels to play
all right uh matchmaking on legend
difficulty yay or nay just one word
answer
nobody
i know
so not not master you don't think legend
should have matchmaking
i no
what's the disadvantage to you of it
having matchmaking since you always play
with your friends
well that's the thing is
i'm i'm i'm i think that at the highest
level if you have to work on builds but
so maybe so maybe not legend maybe
master maybe master yes uh not into no
yeah maybe legend okay because i can
understand i can understand master
because that is you get somebody in
there to know what they're doing you'll
never make progress but master feels
at a reasonable left level with the
artifact power
most people could probably get through
it i feel like yeah yeah i i think i say
yeah i'm sorry
i say yes to matchmaking but you have to
be level 1550. i agree with that
if you just put a level cap on it they
do that yeah they do that in some they
do that in some modes already so just
make the cap 1550. that way you know
that at least a serious player is in
there it's going to join you yeah yeah
yeah i have no horse on the race though
i just i wouldn't play yeah
like psyops
or i mean yeah like psyops would be one
like 1550
nightfalls even at legend at 15.50 those
don't seem like you know if if you you
know get match made and it's got to
check to make sure that you have
you know the champions covered and if
you do
you're good and then you might try and
re and you know maybe leave the group if
they're not good and try again but
i do feel because i sit there and i do a
lot of solo content and you're actually
talking about like the new player
experience because i literally just went
through and did a video new players
against all of the modifiers that
somebody's gonna face
if you look at something higher level
yeah now all the grand masters that
you're doing
somebody's running arbalist
yay nay is somebody running for you guys
yeah so how long do you how how does a
new player acquire arbolest
i don't even i know you're gonna ask me
exactly from the kiosk i guess right do
you have to get spoils and get it from
the kiosk i don't know you either can
hope zur sells it which that's the crap
shoot or you get a random drop which
could be armor or weapons and that's
like every thousand you kills and that
weapon right now in grand masters i mean
there's probably not many guides that
are out there that say
hey you're probably gonna want this one
it's barrier it's every shield
it's linear fusion so you can get your
crits and get a chunk of damage from
range so it's like it hits a whole lot
of buckets and when you get into those
so then you talk about the new player
who yeah that was my recent rant video i
did um
and the new player who
they could grind and now they've put in
the time they've hit 1575. well hey go
grab your arbalist
i don't know how to get that where do i
get it from
i can't get that weapon because it's
pure rng
and that's one of those things when you
mention the new player and it's like
okay because i've been going through
like lost sucker guides i've been doing
them on master and again i'm high enough
to do them but i have options but then i
go through and i'm okay i'm like all
right go from which queen onward
what weapons are available
for
a new player who started which queen
loved the campaign got to 1520 if they
did it on legend powerful grind at this
point probably didn't actually feel that
grindy they're at 1550. okay yeah and
now they've got options that they need
to hit barrier overload and unstoppable
and then you've got different shield
types maybe you need arc maybe you need
solar maybe you need void
and
you get to the point of
you need a solar pulse rifle solar is
like the big standout for whatever
reason because if you need barrier it's
bow or scout
there is one solar bow in the game and
it comes from last wish they probably
haven't done that
four scouts
solar scout pilates corrector i think
might be the only one outside of another
one again vision is in the race yeah c
scout yes he scout dsc okay i was trying
to take raids out of the equation okay
raised out of the equation these are so
little activities so these are solo
people who don't have friends to do
raids with okay but yeah but you can go
grind out exotics and try and get these
things
so there's also a blue scout rifle
that's solar i believe
please take that into a master nightfall
and let me know how that goes
ek does it he really does no he does he
he runs us he runs a he runs a blue
solar scout rifle absolutely it's got i
think it's the only one that's solar and
has explosive
no go ahead though but i see what you're
saying like you're like you don't have
access to that's the idea so that was
the the long train of thought that i
went through was like so if you want a
solar
like a solar scout or pulse or
whatever it was it's like now we do have
adaptive munitions which is starting to
help a little bit
so you're kind of getting there but
again if somebody gets to that point and
as you said the new player experience
it's just rough that's basically the
long-winded way to say that is because
the new player gets the 1550. well let
me start looking on these lost sectors
so in my downtime and i have to do this
by myself anyway i can start building up
my exotic arsenal
you're telling me i need this like
tetris puzzle of overload solar pulse
and kinetic here and then the burn is
void and it's just like with a new
player does look at that it's got to be
it's a lot so as you said the pvp will
help and i think just a little bit more
accessibility and i'm hoping when they
do like solar 3.0 a lot of solar guns
come into the game because we haven't
had a solar bow that's legendary since
last wish and that's been three years so
i'm going how we just gotta avoid one we
have like couple arc ones we keep never
getting solar bows and then the same
thing with arc 3.0 i hope we get a huge
insert of so they really round out all
the archetypes so a lot of different
people have them that's all
that was the biggest problem with sun
setting wasn't it because they sunset so
much stuff yep that you couldn't if you
were looking for a particular like i
wanted to get like a void
avoid
sniper or something like that like
or you know i can't even remember like i
don't remember what i was looking for
but i was like this literally
does not exist the game currently
you know i had one but it was sunsetted
and i deleted it and now i don't have
anything to fit that particular slot so
i see what you're saying i think that
like for new people coming in
all of that is is extremely overwhelming
and how do they how do they even get
there yeah i think that i think that
it's like some of the
i think that when when they introduce
uh intrinsic champion
um to to some of these exotics that
helps a little bit if the exotics
accessible right you know and i think
that that you know that that helps a
little bit but i definitely see your
point that like if you're coming into
the game like how do you how do you get
enough of these pieces of puzzle in
order to be able to complete this these
high-level activities that require you
to have champion champion stuff equipped
it's hard
new players have a hell of a treadmill
ahead of them that's for sure that's
tough uh i'm gonna take like 60 seconds
gambit labs
invasion switching i wanted to ask first
before this came out did this sound fun
because basically the way it works
at 40
and i don't remember the other number
when you get the invasion maybe it's 70.
75. yeah i think it's 75.
your team when you dunk
you decide when the other team's
invasion portal opens
how does that sound like it would play
out before you even start so travis i
know tiddly you played a little
a little little but you got to
experience it travis i don't think you
have yet so in your head
where do you think the strategies are
going to go or how do you think that's
going to go down
uh that so i think we talked about this
on the show when it was announced that
they were going to try this and my first
reaction was
that seems like how it should work
to me
is like based on the other team's
progress you get to invade rather than
your own progress because
uh
yeah i i don't know that just it seems
more like it like huh why why did they
do it the other way where your you
scoring opens up the portal so that you
can enter the other team so
uh different philosophies i
honestly gambit just has so many other
problems i think that this is such a
minor change i was just like all right
cool
maybe that'll work better than the
current system but i still don't think
it's going to fix this
this really just awful experience that i
get when i play gambit so i was not
looking forward to it
i've not played it a bad new player
experience there's like not even a
tutorial to gambit but anyway i know
dude it's so bad it's so
so bad what are these things
on the ground but sometimes fall through
the floor and i'm just um so it's italy
you've played even if it was like a
match or two what'd you experience or
what are you just thoughts on
this experiment
i i think
okay so first of all it doesn't fix the
main issue with the new gambit this
season which is the damage-gated bosses
right because that prolongs
the torment
of gambit
even longer than it should because part
of the satisfying thing about
um
last season's gambit is how how you
could melt the bosses so quickly and i
know that there's certain strategies you
could use to bypass the damage gates in
gambit which i'm not sophisticated
enough to do that but um
i think that that it doesn't fix that
core problem right um that being said
i i do agree that like hypothetically
you know
giving your team the ability to control
when the other team invades seems better
than have giving the other team control
over when you know when they're going to
invade right because then the other team
can kind of strategize oh we're going to
dunk because that's what that's what i
was doing
uh before the update i was like okay
well they
delayed they delayed the first invaded
to 40 right so you dunk 40 you get to
invade right so what people were doing
is because the first invade was
happening so much later is you everyone
gets a big blocker everyone puts the big
blocker in at the same time you get your
invade you go in you do your thing so i
haven't played it enough to know like
what
the current strategy is but it i i don't
think it's a big enough change to make
the mode feel better but i think that
that particular change isn't
doesn't hurt the mode it doesn't make it
worse what i need to know is what
maybe they put this in the 12 but i
don't remember reading this i need to
know what the invasion
um
timeline work how the invasions work
once the primeval summoned because that
that was my experience today i would
like that like the getting up to the
primeval was totally fine the new system
for me totally fine but once you get the
primeval it almost felt like we were
getting invaded constantly once we
summon the primeval and we were winning
we summoned the primeval first and then
it was like invasion invasion invasion
invasion invasion we kept getting killed
and then of course as you know that's
super unfun right like i i i invaded
like i said not a pvp player i'm out
there cheesing you know my gala horn i
got my gala horn i'm running country and
fizz i'm like you know being sneaky i
got four kills on my invade as a
terrible pb play self-admitted terrible
pvp player they had gotten their
primeval down to a quarter got the
entire health back how bad does that
feel for the other team right um you
know but i i don't that's my question my
question is what what was changed about
the invasions once somebody about
somebody's primeval is summoned because
it almost felt like we were being
punished for winning and and and that
also makes the game go longer you know
because what what bungie did
last it sounds like they didn't change
anything
no it doesn't honestly like that the
change may be slightly better but it
doesn't fix the mode
i guess maybe my summary of because the
invasion once you summon the prime evil
the constant invasion that's not new to
gambit that's always been kind of at
least
and i hate that
yeah it's not great
it feels like a ketchup mechanic that uh
is unfair to the team that
performed well during the hard part of
gambit which is like getting the moats
without dying and making them all and
all that stuff so yeah and it also feels
awful it feels awful to get to the
damage gates because you you do get free
heavy right but then you're like i'm not
getting the optimal
return on my heavy if i use my heavy
beef like before the first damage gate
because you know somebody's just gonna
invade and get it back anyway do i use
my heavy now do i use my super now you
know am i going to hold on to it but
then it's going to take longer to get to
the damage gate and some of the envoys
so you're like i
i don't have a good solution but i just
know that i'm i'm still not enjoying it
i i enjoyed it better i enjoyed it
better when they had completely neutered
the mode right because that's why last
season like before they introduced these
changes they basically
pulled everything out of gambit made it
like as vanilla and bland as possible
and for me that was a better experience
and i i don't dislike gambit that's the
thing i don't dislike it i'm not like
like my husband won't even pick it up
he's like i hate this mode you know i
won't play this mode i'll play anything
else i'll play anything else except for
gambit you know but for me i'm like i
was lost i'll
you know so there's got to be some kind
of happy medium between that completely
neutered gambit that we had before the
changes and this sort of like
extensively painful gambit that we
currently have
i don't know
i don't know what the solution is take
pvp out of it with your husband on this
one
you're just like i'm out yeah i don't
actually you know what i i think i
thought about this i did some soul
searching i think i would rather play
the gambit playlist than the strikes
playlist
wow the game interesting game is just
like uh he's explaining here's the thing
here's my here's my ears yeah but see i
can might
always make progression
just on strikes knock out a boss pve but
that's the point it's but it's mindless
but it feels never challenging still get
the satisfaction of like shooting the
destiny guns making the heads explode
hitting your crew i think you don't get
that in gambit
it does i mean you do you get the pve
part and gambit though okay so because
here's the reason just add frustration
and gambit you have like you may have
the same pve but then you had
frustration that doesn't make it to me
there's to me there's nothing more
frustrating than entering this like
bland super boring repetitive i've done
it a thousand times just
mind numbing experience that it strikes
where it's like oh a strike i've done 50
times time to do it again with no
changes
no difference i'm just like going
through it you could turn you could be
in a coma and play the strike playlist
like without really any i mean if you
are correct that's not wrong it is
mind-numbingly easy and i just think i
just think i would rather play a
imbalanced imperfect experience where at
least things are different every match
because there's variables yeah but is it
there's only four maps
there's only certain enemies on the same
maps they don't even have like a
rotation of
advocate i do feel like the one thing
that bungie got right in gambit is the
power fantasy that you have when you're
in the invader because i feel like the
most fun moments i have in gambit even
as a pvp player is when i get a good
invade that is so much fun and gambling
for a one-man army those do feel good
they they feel amazing like i think i
think that's when i'm having fun in
gambit is when i but the thing is
whenever i'm playing gambit especially
if i'm like solo queuing because you
know no one wants to play with me like
you know i i end up fighting blueberries
to invade and so i just kind of don't
and then i end up stuck in this like
situation where i feel powerless but
devil's advocate that's really fun
invading can be really really fun like
those moments oh but the other side how
do you feel about being invaded
that's
terrible i almost that's awful it's
awful
okay this is terrible
i figured out strikes yes
strikes are the xanax um yes
and then gambit is the bipolar disorder
yes it's like i love this i hate this
i'm never playing this again
i think we figured it out and then i
guess i guess i'd rather be frustrated
than bored maybe this is something that
i'm worried about myself i was like
i mean
boring is the worst state for games for
me it is the worst state just straight
up board but that's again what like you
don't have to do those that often
and you don't have to do gambit that
often i don't have to do gambit that
often either i'm just saying if i had to
pick i think i would probably choose
canvas
sprouts of destiny
and then
although i have to say when things
become boring in destiny the thing that
i love about the the guardians in the
game like the players who love this game
is that they find ways to make it
interesting and i'm talking about like
different ways like when i'm playing a
strike even if i'm playing with randoms
i'll go in you know i'll load and i'll
do a skip and i'll pull them forward and
i'll be like haha i bet she didn't know
that that wasn't there you know like and
stuff like that i find that super fun
like like learning something like
sometimes when you notice that's why pv
is fun like you you've done it enough
times you know how to like make things
optimal and i that that can be super fun
but sometimes i i don't i'll it sounds
like you get joy out of skipping past
destiny contest
you enjoy not doing it finding ways to
not do it
how could i not play destiny that's how
i get off
as much of destiny as possible so i can
put it away for a while that's exactly
yeah exactly
but there is something to be said about
how how like
you can do strikes and and not give it
your 100 focus you know because i'll
i'll put up a stream on my other like
monitor and i'll watch a stream and kind
of hang in a stream while i'm grinding
and i find that really fun because i
feel like i'll watch tv shows yeah you
watch tv shows you know you can put up a
podcast like this podcast or whatever
you know and and then you you know
you're
engaging in an enjoyable activity um and
feeling like you're getting stuff done
because i think at its core video games
are
uh
video games are our weird
thing
right
and and and this is just my theory right
because what are we doing we go to work
you know oh well maybe not now maybe we
work from home but we have this job that
we're committed to to make our money you
know and then we come home and what do
we do we turn on the video game and we
start working again why do we do that
what is the compulsion there the human
compulsion
what why do we do that see this yeah
variety i i'm of insanity a lot
yeah see i'm obsessed with working so
the reason i am a gamer is because it
feels like work because it's not
socially acceptable to work 100 percent
of the time so it's like
you know
it gives you a purpose but it's not it's
it's not real it's ones and zeros at the
end of the day it doesn't exist right
you know you you spend you know 15 bucks
on some kind of like cool fortnight skin
you know eventually when fortnite
doesn't exist that's going away right
the amount of time and i mean does the
artifact is a great example of that oh
my gosh i got my artifact level plus 30
you know oh my gosh i got it leveled to
plus 30. i put in all this work to get
the artifact level to plus 30. but
here's the season boom take that away
here's the thing
why do we do that why are we addicted to
working in video games here's the thing
tiddly you say it doesn't matter but all
three of us in this chat have found a
way to make it actually work
we all make money off of it right
that's
we are the minority most of us are who
are even hearing us speak right now very
much the minority the people who find
youtube videos there's the people who
just like oh here's this destiny game i
booted up at night and i kind of do some
stuff like that's
that's the person who
you wonder when you said you're like hey
how fun is this or
when you get invaded you're like that
just so
angry and you're like
that person who does go do their job and
come home and wants a little escape and
gets so frustrated
that's when they do set it down
unfortunately they really have to love
it though they have to love it i think
so because for us to a certain extent it
is work like i have to play destiny
every week otherwise i won't have
anything to talk about on the show so
yeah yeah but okay here's the question
would you do it if you weren't getting
paid
i did before
but i think there were i had more
freedom to not do it in the past so uh
there were periods of my destiny life
where i didn't play for like two or
three months and i have not done that
since i've been on destiny shows and so
uh i think i think in the past i had
more freedom and and i would not do
stuff if it was pissing me off or if it
wasn't productive or whatever and or if
i was just bored by it i would just
check out a destiny for a little while
uh and since making content for it it's
like well now i have to
yeah i gotta log in every week and write
ign's article about zur right
this isn't the same same boat there i
got i got to go see zurer every week so
that's like you know there's stuff i've
got to do yeah it's like i will say for
me
the healthiest destiny is when i don't
live it 24 7. for me personally
tiddly's like my brain just broke
no i don't either though that's the
thing i mean i'm giving a heart yeah i
know yeah i don't do that either though
but like for me the balance of
when you do jump into the strike
playlist just to be like oh i to do a
couple pinnacles but i've been playing
elden ring for 40 or 50 hours or
anything else and then you jump pick in
it feels good for a little while those
things don't feel too bad in smaller
doses it is the point we get to and as
you said that's where the
extended grind the treadmill feels a
little bit longer
depending on where your level is
and again as you said you've always got
people to play with the solo player
versus the person who always has friends
to play with that's also going to be a
different experience too the person who
has friends who gets ready for grand
masters and the raids every week they
have a lot of
do you do have a little more challenge
you got a little more variety stuff to
do that solo player starts to run out
and then if they hear war stories about
lfg they're like
i guess i'll wait till next season
yeah no that's true and i think that's
part of the challenge of grinding too
when you're a little player in terms of
accessing pinnacles it's i think it's
really tough
to get to to like max power when you're
just you know like what are your options
you have strikes you have gambit um you
can do the psyops battlegrounds because
that's matchmade um
you can't do you can't do the 100k
nightfall
that's not accessible to you you know
like you can do you can probably solo uh
the preservation mission if you're like
an average player
it's not too bad you can probably solo
that and that gets you a pinnacle but
that's going to take you longer and it's
not going to be as fun you know like you
your your pool of things you can access
are limited you know i mean
just for pinnacles powerfuls are a
little bit different right but if you're
trying to get to that 1560 base
a lot of the a lot of a lot of the
pinnacles you have to get are are locked
behind
friendship
or at least lfg ship so and that is the
true friend game and that is the end
game the friend game is the end game the
fred game yes as i think that's part of
why we do it to answer your question
from earlier it's like it is a social
experience for some of them even if
you're pissed at the game at least
you're pissed with somebody and also i
mean if you're if this is what you do as
a hobby if you don't make money off of
it you're still um
like what what other hobby are you going
to do that feels more productive than
games you know what i mean like on
somebody's like
doom scrolling tick tock
that's right
[Music]
is watching tv does that feel more
productive than video games like i would
say no so well but i think
it's interesting that you you say
product productive because is that the
end goal of your yours for hobby time it
is for you so like you're it is for me
and it's working productivity
so you're kind of addicted to working
like kind of in the same way
is worth the experience though for sure
for sure but it doesn't feel like work
it feels like you ever get antsy when
you sit and watch i do i'm like super
over tv and movies the past couple years
i just i can't i have to be doing
something else as well my wife and i
and all like enjoy like the acting and
the nuance and like the little character
development and then my wife will still
get most of the show and she'll be
playing like she'll like look up yeah
she'll be doing other stuff the whole
time but she still catches most of it so
i gotta give her props for pretty
impressive those are terrible people to
watch shows with though because you like
look to them and go did you get that and
they're like huh you know are they
interesting because i feel like i have
those moments when i'm like or it's like
hey do you want to watch a movie that i
know she hasn't seen and it's like hey
this is what i like and then i'm like
are we gonna watch the movie
no but they they actually i feel like
television production companies actually
create
um streamable content for that
particular population
like there's a whole there's a whole
series like all there's all the
especially reality tv shows they want
the content to be
interesting and fun but not so
like not take all your time complicated
you it doesn't have to hold your
complete attention they literally do
that that's why people binge watch these
these shows they're not you're not they
don't intend you to like intend you to
give your full 100 attention the entire
time nobody's paying full attention
for you to multitask no one's doing i
don't even know what that is
is it cake it was like the top show on
netflix like a couple weeks ago it's
just a show where oh yeah yeah that kind
of show that is a perfect example great
example nobody is watching that full of
no no one oh people are doing something
else when they're watching that show
that's like a show you watch while
you're jogging you're like on the
treadmill and you have it on your phone
for sure exactly exactly right well the
last thing i did want to ask so is the
end of the twab
touched on one thing that because we
basically blew through most of the twab
uh shout out by the way to the bungee
foundation they do have the kilts for
kids uh that's their annual foundation
with the seattle ronald mcdonald house
that they're working on 11 years strong
um again if you donate for that you got
an emblem that you can get and then
obviously some art in there if you if
you're generous and you've got a
thousand dollars to donate you can also
buy yourself basically a new
brand new headquarters studio tour so
you'll be you got to take care of your
travel and all that stuff but that
basically is
awesome charity donation i also let you
go check it out
it also seems like the destiny community
had a good time in reddit over the
weekend
the uh
r slash place when they make those
really big pixelated pieces of art where
people buy or basically kind of claim
pixels they actually made a really cool
they did a ghost
the witch queen emblem traveler witness
couple pyramid ships
all of this and just like pixel art it
was actually very impressive what they
put together there's a free emblem
if you guys haven't got it yet it's
actually a cool emblem i actually like
that one that we get for free
yeah everyone's nice
but the big one is the end of the twab
and one freelance trials is kicking off
this weekend this is pretty much when i
play trials because i know i'm not gonna
face a three stack so i may win some i
may lose some but i don't have to check
the roster to know if it's just gonna be
uh ass kicking each time
because usually if it's three stack i
beat one three stack last weekend in
zone capture i will say i was and not me
specifically but it was like
there was a pretty solid guy on our team
and the two of us we put it together i
think it ended up being about three like
five three or five four it was close but
we actually beat a three sack i was like
all right
those moments actually do feel pretty
good but
i enjoy because i never have to worry
about that i'm gonna win some i'm going
to lose some but i will get some
reputation some engrams and again for
the solo player alacrity is a very good
perk so spend some time in trials i
can't say that enough but the biggest
one speaking of raids master difficulty
is going to start on the 19th i know
tiddly's going to be ready for that one
because she's going to be level 1600
because she just grinds and grinds and
grinds we know that definitely not
but
tune in next thursday for some fun news
concerning an upcoming rotator of sorts
in season 17.
and this was actually probably the most
exciting thing i've read on twitter in a
little while because i feel like they
mentioned this like a year ago
it's been a while
and we have the legacy playlist and we
have
vault of glass we have basically
everything except um everything that was
on the leviathan because you've got last
wish you've got garden of salvation
beyond light um
deep stone crypt
vault of glass and then now valve the
disciple but they always just put the
newest one for six months up there and
i'm sure when we get the new one in
season 18 whatever that's going to be
that's going to take val the disciple
and knock off its pinnacle rewards but
it sounds like
we might get a rotator of some version
maybe they'll be bringing that to
pinnacles what do you guys think of this
i'm curious do you guys think they will
do a pinnacle rotate or is it just that
simple or do you think they're doing
something else with it
god i hope they do a rotator this has
been and also this is sort of the reason
why i think it's unfortunate that
they've been vaulting so many things
because i feel like if you have a
rotator you kind of don't need the vault
because it points people towards
specific activities you know because
part of the
part of the reasoning that they said
that they were taking out uh content was
just to optimize the game because they
couldn't keep it in there yeah and the
the file size and stuff i kind of don't
believe that frankly just because
there's games that are much bigger than
destiny and they do just fine i think it
was more about player base destiny often
falls to smaller player bases we're
actually currently in kind of a smaller
player base cycle which is totally fine
and i think healthy for games as a
service games
but
it uh
this would solve the problem if they
would have just created some sort of
like rotating playlist or kept all the
strikes within the strike playlist or
kept all the crucible maps within the
crucible playlist you don't have to
take content out if you just
will create these rotating playlists and
so i really hope that they're adding a
raid a rotator i i would love that it
would
totally rejuvenate the the old raids and
the ability to play it give people more
opportunities to go for those exotics
without having to
get stuck in an old raid that doesn't
reward you on the on the the bleak hope
that you'll actually get some good loot
from it or an exotic that you're missing
um so yeah i'm uh i've been on this on
this train for a while and i really hope
that they do it because it's it's
overdue in my my opinion
goodly
i think it's a fantastic idea i mean the
way i'm kind of picturing it is
the way uh grand masters work where you
have like a particular nightfall that's
available or just regular nightfalls
however a particular nightfall available
that week
and then you you can you have access to
that you can play it that week and then
it's a different one the next week um
and then basically using
using the raids that they sunset not
destiny one rate just the raids that
they sunset for destiny 2. right oh you
want them to bring back leviathan
i mean i want them to bring back um
eater of worlds actually okay but i mean
i think there's a lot i mean
you know ask somebody else it's gonna be
spire stars or like you know what i mean
everybody has their favorite
raid that's been sunset crown of crown
of sorrows that's so much fun you know
but so that's the way i see it playing
out ideally and i think that they did
kind of mention
that
um that there would be possibility of
earning some kind of reward for
completing it so like get allowing that
be being a pinnacle activity maybe not
the way that valve disciple gives you a
plus two pinnacle like for every single
encounter you complete but maybe giving
you a one pinnacle at the end every time
you completed that like if you complete
it once that week you get a pinnacle at
the end of the raid something like that
will be really fantastic give people the
reason to play it um yeah
and i but i do think that they keep the
normal raid playlist or does this
replace it part way through the season
once the new raid is sort of old there
is no raid playlist
you know what i mean like right now the
raid playlist is you have to play the
new raid oh you just mean like
the pinnacles yeah i get what you mean
yeah i'm saying do they do they do they
is this additive or does it replace the
new raid after a couple i would say i
would say additive i would say that
essentially essentially it doesn't
replace vow is the optimal source of
raids to get pinnacles but then give
give them a pinnacle at the end of
completing the first time right that
week right um and then give you know
suppose of some sort you know for
replayability um i think that the the
remastered raids like like um like fog i
think
my understanding is that takes a massive
amount of resources and time in terms of
bringing those to light and destiny too
it's not just copy and paste from one to
the other in terms of the content so i
don't see those i mean i don't see those
as being kind of like part of that
rotation um but rotating the sunsetted
raids would be so so fantastic i would
absolutely love that and adding a title
to that would also be super fun too
you know i would love that idea yeah see
my curiosity is one as you said you've
got the sunset rates i actually hadn't
thought about most of leviathan scourge
that type of stuff that's actually been
taken out because again i don't know if
that takes them putting assets back in
the game them trying to keep the game
size down i didn't think about that but
i would love to see that because he said
it's d2 but again i don't know how much
polish work it takes to take the d2
stuff into like the newer lighting
engine and stuff that they've done still
within d2 because they've done some
engine modifications with beyond light
and witch queen so i don't know what it
takes for that one but even then if you
take just the five that are there
the ones that we just got done
mentioning those five again if you do
no there's no reason to run garden of
salvation right now but if there's
pinnacles in there you got sherpas that
have a reason to run people through it
you've got more people that are going to
have a reason to teach it and learn the
different raids and gives more life to
those i also wonder
at this point they basically said
crafting
is
mostly based around the season that
we've got right now season 16 witch
queen and then they said they were going
to open up
yeah divinity would be a good reason to
run garden for more people but that's
yeah you actually have to get that one
on rotation but then you have crafting
is supposed to expand to
season 17 stuff which we'll get some
more and then they said some older stuff
as well and i'm wondering if some of the
older stuff either
if they're going to bring
if there's featured raids if those could
have some possible red outline weapons
where you can actually start crafting
some of those
i also wonder if they would do origin
traits for some of the previous raids
yeah origin traits too all of that
like garden of salvation or origin
traits to deep stone crypt or anything
like that just to get more variety and
more reason for everybody to run those
again
because if you can get another trustee
or another
what is the sniper rifle in uh deep
stone crypt where it's like
reconstruction and recombination like
the god roll of all the ammo type one i
can't i don't know i use it all the time
though
that one's amazing all the deep stone
guns are amazing the the the shock on
the the kinetic shock gun they're all so
good so if you could yeah
i use that shark a lot yeah so if you
could do that and then now you have a
reason to go back and you get an origin
trait paired with it as well plus if
it's a certain family or anything like
that that i think would be the best
version do i think we're going to get
the raids the pinnacles and the origin
traits maybe any weapon crafting that's
probably asking a little too much but i
think the origin traits would give a
reason for everybody to run because as
you said if it's like one pinnacle or
maybe two pinnacles from a raid
once you hit that 1560 a lot of people
will lose the
reason to run that list
yeah i'm done with doing pinnacles
because i'm 1560 based so i'm not going
to be doing any more pinnacles i have no
reason i don't have to ever do my
repeated gambit three games of gambit a
week ever again this season i've done
i've never have i'm done yep so
introducing raid rotators with pinnacles
at this point in the season is is
asinine it's not a good idea but
introducing at the beginning of a new
season now that's interesting and fun
and people will play it until they hit
the pinnacle cap
um and i don't also
i i think we're all just talking about
raids uh because it's the obvious one
but i want i also think that they they
yeah so i was gonna say they they badly
need to do it for dungeons as well i
think favorite what would that look like
a dungeon rotator i mean because right
now you've got shattered throne you've
got grasp which is the pinnacle but
you've got prophecy you've got pit of
heresy and what if just one of those a
week is going to be
you know a pinnacle the same thing if
you get origin traits in those anything
like that just to give because you have
a lot of dungeons which are that's a
solo low man level content they're built
around one person and then three people
can do them it's built for that other
less
sized group like person either they know
one or two people or they don't know the
big group of six for a raid that's the
other side where i think that i really
hope they do that too because that type
of rotation gives a different player
base something else to go do
and we get a dungeon next season
yeah
well that's a good idea
yeah so i was like that was the one
thing i saw is because you just said i
was like i love shattered throne i have
zero reason to go run it pit of heresy
the same way it's a cool experience
prophecy like if you've never seen
prophecy that's one of the trippiest
things that you'll ever go through
especially trying to i love prophecy so
good the cube room and the boss fight
rotating playlist with pinnacles would
definitely be a reason to do it making
those weapons only drop
their craftable versions if they if you
know if they were in the weekly playlist
is a great way so yeah they got a lot of
tools at their disposal i just i would
like to see them
i think everything's a real reason to
replay
the older raids and the the the you know
you know the shadow thrown the dungeons
is is like
like loot is specifically tied to
whatever that is because i i was running
let's see what were you doing we were
doing
um last wish just the last bit of it
we were basically checkpointing and
doing last wish ones for 1k when um like
that was just so overpowered last season
you know so like or where i was running
um
garden the garden initial encounter on
three characters just for that bow
the garden bow is really really really
good it's really really good so um and
when i once i got a god roll i was like
okay well i'm done doing that but i
think that there but if you attach
something else to that if i was able to
craft
that garden bow
then that would give me as as like you
said this like nerdy i'm happy to do the
content over and over player a reason to
run garden over and over so i could
craft a garden bow even though i have a
god roll one additional grind i could
craft one with maybe like enhanced perks
that's even better than the current one
that i have so that's yeah i think
crafting is like their solution to
making optional end game content for
people who really are looking for things
to do in destiny but they don't want to
uh
give fomo because i think the average
player does not care at all about
crafted weapons as much as the same
level that they care about like god
rolling grinding for god rules right uh
but it's catnip for their dedicated
players so i could really see that
becoming something they lean on in the
future and i say you know just lean into
it because uh i'll engage in some of it
but i i also never really grind it for
god rules either and i don't think i'll
probably grind for a lot of the crafted
weapons yeah maybe trials but that's
about it so yeah i'm not enjoying
crafting honestly like i i don't
yeah
personally i just i don't like the
initial part where you have to use a
weapon that's not good in order to
exactly you have to use a crappy weapon
that's sort of my problem with it too
fun it's really not fun i would rather
go into the game with weapons that i'm
comfortable with that are fun to use
um so i i haven't really been engaging
in with a ton of it and i feel kind of
really shameful admissions of a grinder
you know of all yeah that's very
surprising yeah that's like that one was
built for you come on just go into
strikes man
i don't want to
go into the strike playlist that you can
mindlessly do while you're watching that
show and then take your three sorry
that's right and just shoot stuff with
that auto really full
turn on turn on that stream jump into
the strikes playlist take all your red
frames with you just grind out this oh
god oh my god the red frames don't get
me started oh my god that was like that
the man that
the way they managed to make vault space
somehow worse and then we heard
we heard the currencies could have been
much worse now you have this temporary
seven-week window where you have these
currencies but then you're knowing those
are all gonna go away in seven weeks so
why am i
carrying and then the neutral element
went up by like 12 while the other ones
went up by like 400 and that's just a
weird math problem that doesn't make
sense in my head and we talked about
that before
i'm like i'm pac i'm like maxed out on
neutral element constantly
but i'm sitting there like i have like
oh i have 322 a droid element or
whatever it is i'm like that's fine the
neutrals still maxed out so doing all
this doesn't do me any good and i can't
spend the rest and then it's going away
so
no the
yeah that's crafting i'm hoping we get
some good tweaks to crafting but as you
guys said the tools
are there between origin traits to give
variety to some of the stuff like the
raid rotators the dungeon rotators and
then crafting as well if they make it
less
painful and then also let me use the
junk weapon for like because then you
don't want to craft the junk weapon
unlock some of the perks and get to like
level eight and be like okay it's not as
bad but it's not there so then i feel
like i'm wasting resources
to then actually get it to like level 13
at least then i can take the good ish
the good perks
to use for a while and see which ones i
like and then maybe i'm gonna go spend
some asinine amount of currency on the
enhanced ones which most of them are not
worth it
most and there's just only slightly
better than the other ones which to be
fair kind of going back to the other
point we're talking about you know
locking something that is absolutely
so much better behind that kind of grind
is bad for the regular players right
because then that forces people into the
crafting system to get whatever is way
way better i don't think they could have
put out enhanced perks they were way way
better because then they would force
people to do this system and not
everyone's going to want to do it this
is true but then on the other side
unfortunately it makes a person like you
who
could potentially love crafting not find
much incentive in it well right because
like i said i i've run the raid i'm
working on getting my red border weapons
but i already got a god roll um smg from
the raid yeah so am i really going to go
through all that effort to get a
slightly better version of it yeah you
never need same thing as like an adapt
weapon it's not necessary
no you don't need it you don't need it
like you don't need to be max power to
do trials you don't need it yep
yeah i can enjoy playing the game
without it
and that's kind of the weird part for
like the end game of destiny right now
is the fact that you get to
you get to a point where your loadout is
good enough to do everything that you
want to do whether you're a solo player
working on grinding some lost sectors
whether you're tiddly and you're
grinding grand masters but you still you
have enough
of a capable arsenal somewhere in your
vault to get what you need done and then
you get to that point where you know
if you're comfortable you know doing
stuff over and over because you enjoy
the continent you have friends then
that's the friend game end game
but that's the weird point that's that
weird balance we were talking about and
again that's that constantly like
teetering balance thing that they're
like what's good for the more casual
player versus the end game you said you
can't make it too good
but if it's not too good is it worth
going after that's always the weird
balance in this yeah no i think it i
think that bungie
is always trying to sort of optimize
that balance and that's one of the
benefits of having a a game with live
updates yeah you know and it's it's one
of the challenges and certainly the
community is incredibly challenging you
know there's a lot of people who are
really smart who give this a lot of
thought who who are very critical about
the game and in many different ways um
but
i don't know at the end of the day at
the end of the day it's fun we keep
picking i'm picking it up so yeah
yeah we still have thousands of hours so
it's not like i hate the game we just
always want to see it a little bit
better
absolutely and there's nothing wrong
with that wanting wanting something that
you love to be even better
and then we got one more super chat from
mri gamer okay i'm back to send love to
thai guy travis as long as he gets me to
the lighthouse
happy though oh carries we do carries
now
yeah i've done i've helped some people
on this show in the comments section go
to the lighthouse um so yeah happy to do
it as long as it's not during a uh
control week because i stayed super far
away from charles this weekend oh zone
zone capture or whatever it is yeah that
was yeah yeah but that's a fun titan
bubble mode though you don't run titan
it is it was but it is certainly a watch
it is certainly a titan bubble mode but
i would i would debate uh the fun part
of it um oh not really
not really it became bubble
and venn diagram bubble that kind of
overlapped
and then it became shield and shield and
shield and shield
and six of them are stacked on top of
each other and it's a game of chicken of
who's going to
punch wiggle through get the shot off
but oh it was not it was just like there
were a couple of likes
i saw on twitter where it was a mess
shout out to dj rose with the hashtag
friend game in game as well of course
but yeah i know it's like zone capture
with void 3.0
needs the solar and arc 3.0 needs some
kind of counter that's the point where i
keep like i want those other two to see
how they can try and
work around that and it's just it's
when you saw the double bubble go down i
was like
oh god this is gonna be a mess and then
like shield shield
it was it was a bit of a mess i played i
played enough where it happened a couple
times and i'm on a site and so of course
i'm going to be the bubble guy
and yeah titan titan train was
definitely running running on trials
this weekend it was a bit of a mess but
yeah that's actually funny this weekend
normal feeling
well thank god
that's a nice tight little two-hour show
is there anything else you guys want to
talk about tiddly anything else in the
world of your mind about destiny that
you want to get off your chest
um
i'll just say that
um we got just one thing
i always have something more to say
um
i think i think for me
like part of the reason that people are
so critical about the game is because
they love the game so much so i i always
try to be constructively critical when
i'm critical of the game and sometimes i
ask questions where there's no good
answer because you know you know it's
just kind of out in the ether but
um i think that's part of the reason
that the community is so engaged and and
also like in terms of conversing with
you know the like the devs and
everything like that i think that people
love the game i think that um and that's
fantastic i think that
basically
destiny players exist in this state it's
like antithetical to apathy like we're
passionate about the game yes we might
get angry sometimes yes we might get
critical sometimes but it's not because
we don't care it comes from a place
of love of this video game so i see that
as a holy positive thing i think that
certainly it can be expressed
in in a not so great way sometimes but i
think generally speaking i think that i
i love this community because they do
they are so passionate about this video
game
no i mean that makes perfect sense if we
were apathetic about it we probably
wouldn't play it
absolutely i'm going to complain again
about campus still though oh that's fair
i mean travis is going to complain about
strikes
i'm going to complain about the the the
new player lost sector experience we all
have our pieces that we'd love to see
better and it's the balance of
bungie and teams and live service and
bandwidth to get
everything done at the same time which
is impossible and we know that so that
we know they're building another season
we know
if you saw the development chart from
gdc that like multiple seasons are in
development at the same time and then we
have to try and ask for these other
quality of life fixes and we get
a couple of them every season not all of
them work out well crafting we got
crafting beta 0.8 version we're not
quite at 1.0 yet we got the beta we're
working on it we got some ironing out to
do we got some yeah some corners to
smooth out but we'll get there yep
but overall yes i think that is
i think that is one of the reasons is
i've we've probably said this on the
show before too it is a game of so much
potential
that when we see a glimmer of something
that we know could be there
that we even get more critical and
excited because we're like oh this could
totally be
this we see it's it's it's like it's out
just out of reach and i want to i want
to go grab it but it's not quite there
right now right and it's frustrating
when it doesn't meet what we expect but
at the same time i think
i think we we also have moderately
unrealistic expectations sometimes
and i sometimes i also think that the
when when bungie is at its best is when
they throw stuff against the wall and
see if it sticks that's how trials was
created which is arguably one of the
best things that's happened to the game
so i
wish every creative
random thing for them to think of to add
to the game to make it more fun i want
them to take risks i i don't want to i
don't want them to listen to me as
someone who's critical of the game
because i'm thinking in the context of
the game as it exists i want them to
continue to like grow and change and
make super cool new things and yeah some
of them are gonna really be bad and
that's okay but some of them are gonna
be amazing and i think that that's
that's part of like a live game
experience and that's partly part of why
what keeps us coming back you know so
yeah nope that is
very well said and i think that's a good
way to wrap that one up as well
uh yeah as we wrap up the show i first
want to thank you tiddly for taking the
time you know it's a couple out of hours
of your streaming and time with your
man and all that type of stuff that
we're taking away from so thank you
i'm still spending time with my cat
though that is true you got fluff you
are you are conan fluff
uh well thank you for bringing flowers
onto the show that is also a first time
we appreciate that it makes the stream
much prettier
than these ugly mugs that we've got here
so we thank you
for bringing the attractiveness of the
show up next time i'll bring my tie
though i i feel underdressed i was gonna
say like you've talked about d and d you
said trials is one of the best things
that was brought to the game like you
are pitching to the travis choir right
now you have no idea
amazing ties i have some really nice
ties bow ties i get rocket next time i'm
bringing a tie
for sure well we will definitely have
you back this was an absolute blast we
had this was so much fun thank you so
much for having me i love talking about
this game and you guys are great i
actually you know it's it's rare
when i'm when i'm talking to people
about the game that they they make me
think about it in a different way and
both of you did that tonight and i
really appreciate that so thank you so
much for a good conversation very nice
love that stimulating
well at this point the floor is yours so
anybody who sees this in all the
different places we put this show um
just gotta let people know where to find
you what you'll be doing
um yeah the floor is yours to say
anything you feel like saying within
reason of course
i've seen your streams i know we kind of
got to put a camera listen
did i swear once i was very very good i
well borderline maybe okay um so anyway
i i create content on twitch twitch.tv
for slash tiddly i'm live monday through
friday nine o'clock cst streamer time
which means not always right on time um
and i you know i stream in the mornings
i i think of my content as kind of um
a super energetic morning show i'm a
more really obnoxiously happy morning
person so if you're into that then um
and you need a little like you know
personality caffeine in the morning
that's kind of what i try to provide for
people um you know and that's that's
where you can find me and um certainly
you can follow me on twitter i do my go
lives on twitter i sometimes will post
my destiny hot takes on twitter um but
you know there you go come by if you
want to that's a good incentive is
anything i don't know if i've seen
personality caffeine in the morning
that's pretty good
that's pretty true that's what i try to
provide
yeah a good pick-me-up just by being
again your infectious personality as i
jumped in the stream i don't know what
conversation i jumped into but i was
laughing trying to figure out what was
happening because it was a weird
conversation that's about right
sounds about right yep
travis what about you man uh i know we
have secrets coming from you sometime
but a little bit yeah a very sad scene
i just want to create like a guy on the
side of the pool when they're judging
dives and be like two
yeah
so yeah that's me for sure so yeah i am
i am reviewing a game i can't really
talk about yet but uh
it's a bad game and i'm going to be
telling people not to play it uh i think
next week is when the embargo lifts um
and uh other than that i did a preview
of a game called super fuse at game
developer conference that's on ign um
done some other reviews we were talking
about tiny tina earlier i reviewed that
you can watch that on the site um and
then also you can you can watch me on
sunday mornings on a show called bitcast
where i get into it with ainsley bowden
and uh richard hogue the
lawyer gamer content creator that lots
of people uh know and and presumably
love these days
um you can see me fight with him about
star wars and other topics we're gonna
be talking about lego star wars this
week so i'm sure that will be
contentious
um
halo show thoughts on what's up oh yeah
the halo show so i have not seen episode
three so i need to get on that um but
yeah he may have retired from the show
after that one he hates it yeah he hates
it he's gonna he's gonna stop watching
it i think
um so yeah uh but yeah that's on that's
on sunday mornings at 8 a.m pacific uh
yeah i wake up early for that one um and
uh other than that you can follow me on
twitter at thai guy travis and read my
articles on ign and uh yeah it's good
times also you know
hit me up on destiny i guess yeah and
and also if you're in san francisco go
and enjoy a tabletop game that's right
that's right if you're in san francisco
hit me up we'll play some rpgs tabletop
rpg this is the man well i don't think
we could have had a better guest for
travis just to pick the brain of a d d
cognito we missed you but i think ty guy
was in his bag on this one i think he
was way too excited i had to reel us
back into the destiny show it could have
did a great job it could have been d for
two hours some people would probably
have been like cool this is a variety
show others would have been like i'm out
but it was a great balance and it's
honestly that's kind of why i like
bringing so many different people on the
show is we get to let somebody and if if
i find that little thing where i can
like kind of pop the seal on the
tupperware and like let somebody really
go crazy about a topic they're really
like excited about i always liked seeing
somebody do that so when it was like d
and d i saw both of you go at it i was
like oh that's just that's that's
content right there it's just easy and
but it's when you're passionate about
something it's easy to see people talk
about it so whatever it is it's nice to
see you open up so it's very cool to get
another side of you which i was very
happy to see so
uh but for me ibontis i'll be streaming
eldering until i beat that damn game so
that's like a lot of my variety streams
outside of destiny of course i will be
doing um i suggest you try that if you
like all these crazy challenges in
destiny
i don't know if you like action type
games
but i get but but you do like challenges
though so it does seem like something
that might speak to you and it is kind
of an amazing game so
i will be doing that freelance trials
this weekend as much as i can squeeze
that in trying to work on my reputation
grind there trying to get a couple guns
that i know i want and then other than
that tuesdays have been raided a lot of
eldering that's where i'm at mostly so
and for the gentleman who isn't here
iron lords podcast it will be on sunday
of course make sure you guys check out
iron lord's podcast
um follow lord cognito and of course
um we missed him but
but but we'll get him yeah defining duke
as well
oh yeah i actually got to uh be on
defining duke ultimate so if you
subscribe to last stand media and you
get their kind of early access or their
bonus shows i got to do the witch queen
uh basically spoiler cast with them so
that was actually very fun and kind of
an enjoyable piece because i didn't have
to play host so i just got to ramble for
a little while so that was i got to be
in my bag for a bit
well for this episode i think this is
where we're at chat you guys have been
amazing the super chats have been
awesome today thank you guys for all the
support as always
um any of you who came over from
tiddly's community thank you for being
here you guys kept chat interesting
uh but for this episode as we wrap this
one up thank you guys everybody and for
this episode it has been